[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
and we are live what a new mic
[Music]
[Music]
up what's going on gang plato is out
here first knees taste turf the lords
are here you already know lydian master
what's going on
let me know how my levels are sounding
like i said new audio set up
so oh thank you mr frodo thank you sir
yeah let me ask you this
um obviously it's new like would you say
better louder clearer
you know just in comparison to the old
setup because again who said i just want
to
see how that uh sounds corey mosley
what's going on
floyd lords of gaming you already know
we're gonna have some fun in here so
yeah let me know
what you think in comparison to how the
old mic sounded
do i need to turn up
[Music]
[Music]
oh it sounds like i'm sitting right next
to the mic okay okay okay
i guess that's good that's good because
that's how i get these uh
uh sure microphones you know what i mean
coming in clean the base for that ah
thank you chicken j
my
[Music]
mike
anyway it's gonna be fun y'all we're
gonna get uh the legendary damn butch go
up in here
gotta find out what's going on with
attic we'll see if he'll pull up so i
should pull up
and of course the king will be pulling
up with music in tow
so we will mute him because we don't
want copyright strikes
hope everybody's good chilling and
i will see y'all be right back
gotta give it to a couple childs for a
living tetris
weathersby some car was going on hey
gerald
mack was good or shout out to high the
ilp
ksi very clear what kind of upgrade this
is the shore what is it s7
mb whatever the mic joe rogan is that
way
so i've never really used one of them
xlr mics before
all right i gotta run i'll be back
people in the room
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind
go ahead and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical
and yeah i be eating these rappers but
that's all a part of me being
accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
they don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beating
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
then they will mistake me for addict if
i can imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron
cause if you don't give her that option
you're gonna be single player like siren
you're gonna get tossed in the bushes by
king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental was an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though
i know it's my destiny word to cognito
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news
even if you really was that you can't
never still be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible whether that
nothing is cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle
on a lord's day
[Music]
all right and we are
live welcome to the iron lords podcast
llc and also live on lords of gaming.net
episode number 216. it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's date
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got
play nyc
skyward sword hd
[Music]
switch online announcement and sony stay
to play to discuss
so we gonna get right into it i want to
introduce a lord who is not only a good
friend of the realm of the iop
but whose passion for the cultivation of
independent game development
is truly a sight to behold whether it be
educating those with the business side
of indie games or creating a community
of future developers through interactive
events
this lord is a beacon of inclusion in
that new york entrepreneurial spirit
introducing the ceo and founder of play
crafting
producer of the bid awards and the play
nyc
gaming convention the lord
of global game jams and come
july 16th will unite with lord king on
their
favorite zelda ever that skyward sword
live from new york city and making his
return
into the realm of the lord my man
lord dan butchko how are we doing sir
i i think i need to bring you along
anytime i speak at an event to just like
give me an introduction
because you're so much better at talking
about me than i am
absolute pleasure you all lord at what
you do man it is
absolutely a pleasure to have you back
in the round first off how you been i
think recently you went through like a a
big
move and then um if you have you got a
chance to get
any gaming in sir so just what's going
on with you man oh yeah yeah so i
i just moved back into the city after
about a year year and a half away
um very big move but
the world is opening up new york is
going back to normal so
it feels so nice to finally be back in
the best city in the entire world yeah
can't complain can't complain um and
yeah of course getting some gaming in
for sure um right now all i have here in
my new apartment
is uh my ps5 so
um i've been a little thirsty for
exclusives but we can get into that a
little bit
my condolences are yeah it's been there
but it's cool so just getting adjusted
back into the you know they got the new
place going so wait wait
a question all the consoles are tho
those in transit or
what's going on yeah so i came here with
the ps5
um my next get is my switch now the
problem is
that in my year plus living back home
with my parents
we were playing animal crossing on my
switch every single day
and my my mom fell in love with it and
plays it religiously
every single day to this day i think she
has like 600 hours in there or something
yeah i got to figure out how i can like
get a new switch
and let her keep just my animal crossing
save
and everything else that's right yeah
yeah yeah
well well you know what luckily you're
in luck
nintendo just announced
there we go
before we start i think some super
chat's guessing which i came in i just
see one right yeah
so we got a five dollar superstar jared
mack lower cognito needs to put a patent
to uh put a pattern on every damn near
every word he says
all hell the i'll be absolutely general
much love much love people
running around with the verbiage you see
a lot of lords versus all we ask is pay
homage to
the sports where you heard it from you
heard it oh you know what but what
what might happen is they might hear it
from somebody else and think it started
yeah that's true lord started a lot of
sayings but it's
all good good to have lord dan in the
realm and you already know we got the
four well looks like
three horsemen of gaming hopefully lord
solve will be coming in hot
but the original lords of the realm at
the round table with
some time-sensitive intros because we
guys still respect dan here
no doubt but co-host with the co-host my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his own
world and the how
of the young wolf mommy lord addict how
are we doing sir
doing pretty good uh i ain't really done
a whole lot in
terms of game i played a lot of persona
5 royale this week but uh
i i got to tell people man go on there
on netflix and try that
fear street like really good
those are good like it kind of gives me
like they switch stuff
up every movie it looks like there's
three movies yes three of them and uh
like i'm like i'm sitting going out of
the first one like this is this is a
great show
then i get to the second one and i
finish the second one i'm like how did
they beat the first one like
no doubt you got high hopes for the
third one right
yeah but but i've seen people have
really good
starts and then they just like oh we put
all the money in the first couple
they proved why they the king of the
streaming stuff man
yeah they killed it they killed it and
of course well we're waiting on our
technical game
hopefully he will be here but of course
we have the incredible hulk of this
aka the access gamer
the prophet of xbox king of the statues
who demands nothing less than that
premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir i'm
doing better than conor mcgregor
[Laughter]
like i feel like i feel like anderson
silva don't put a curse on that place
with the leg breaks no no listen let me
let me tell you something what happens
when when you have uh you make 180
million dollars
in a year and you
the fight purse doesn't even cover what
you making endorsements
you know um it really doesn't make any
sense the reason why his ankles gave out
because he has gucci ankles now
okay that's the buddy
is accustomed to the gucci yeah that
messed up the train remember
he's also the owner proprietor of proper
12.
yeah and proper 12 is making great money
uh throughout the world and it tastes
fantastic shout out to proper 12.
but i must say you know um
he doesn't have hard working ankles
anymore
you know like he himself may want it
but his ankles didn't thank you
and you know hopefully my ankles can get
as weak and soft as his
um oh you you're encouraging that kind
of ankle that
that your feet no longer wants to
participate in rough stuff
that's it that's it so now shout out to
connor in his retirement god bless
stay away the game does not need you you
do not need the game you have far
succeeded uh past what you needed to do
and
you're rich sir you're rich you're
famous and you have your health you're
starting to lose your health
just walk away i'm walking away his ego
won't get in the way he has to
okay until something really tragic
happens it starts with the ankle and
ends with something else
you know it could have been a whole lot
worse he'll throw away his whole body
before he admits someone beat him
yes with him is the pride
how long does he stay in you know
because you know his mom because notice
noticing
it no you saw when he was on the floor
right he was screaming doctor stoppers
doctors yeah
yeah he cared about the the terminology
of the loss
like he
he wants that everyone says he's the
best like yeah
but that's it you know time sensitive
anyway um
uh i watch black widow in the house uh
with the family
and it you know shout out to disney plus
for saving me over a hundred and fifty
dollars
had i had to get up for every
subscription
i would have had to get popcorn my kids
would somebody would have to go to the
bathroom
in between and i do not care for that
and i don't care for anybody being drunk
in a movie theater
i i really just had a fantastic time in
a house with the family
watching a movie that i can stop pause
rewind and check out
oh are you are you implying that you may
be done with the
theater sir thank you for the thing you
know certain silver linings happen
in a pandemic and this is one of those
silver linings that i
will take full advantage of 29.95 uh
they have my cash i've been playing and
it was it's a great movie i have a new
crush
uh oh yes oh oh oh okay
buried man excuse me sir i'm just
married men on the panel here i'm not
blind
yeah yeah like wait wait a second just
because you are somebody you're just
supposed to be like
nothing else
[Laughter]
[Music]
he said i wish i ran a milk company i
would do ufc sponsorship salute
he agrees with king thank you much
cheaper to do it
we got it todd says i got to back up
because we've got
the the the smooth one has arrived you
know what i'm saying
just let me just finish i've been
playing
for you before before you try to take
away your time
from the guy that was actually here to
give
uh dragon quest oh my god dragon quest
eleven um
it's such a phenomenal game it is
absolutely and i i
i really appreciate every time i play
the game
every time i do a spell it just hawkins
back and it
didn't lose its essence of an rpg a
traditional rpg
and i love that stuff so much it
awakened
more rpg ness inside of me every time
leica dragons come out every time dragon
quest is on its 12th installment
and it's still popping every time
persona comes out for very successful
uh friend entry in the franchise
i'm over there looking to squeeze him
like yeah yeah yeah
yeah like these people stayed to their
true core and they
and they they worked with this like you
you bounced like you was like
we leaving like yeah no abs absolutely
that's why because me and um me and
megatron were talking like
like microsoft man anyone watching here
from microsoft
hit up mr walker and get that blue
dragon going man
please i love that yeah lost odyssey
let's go
no doubt i think blue dragon's more like
dragon quest so i think it would like
resonate with people more
right now and of course jordan coming in
hot like the switch
our most technical gaming lord the solo
game who lives for the single-player
selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity and lord patriarch of the iron
bank
my man lord simon how we doing sir good
afternoon gentlemen what's going on yeah
coming in very high
i was going uh i was looking at uh
properties so i'm sorry
excuse me yeah yeah that's very
[Laughter]
shout out and welcome to lord blitzkill
welcome back to the realm sir
thanks so much good to see you likewise
likewise
um yeah everything's good you know
missed you yesterday at uh
i picked theaters uh i had the boozy
experience last night went to see uh
uh what you would call it um black i
don't even remember the name
black widow um it was good to be back in
the theater i know
i i definitely know what king's talking
about because king king has a lot of
people to take care of nothing
don't worry about it thank you but um it
was good to be in the theater having my
norma gene you know
and lord cogs absolutely appreciate it
i'm healing
i enjoyed it i really enjoyed it i
thought there were certain
edits that kind of cut the movie weirdly
short for me like it just felt like
there were certain parts where you could
have had more exposition um
and in terms of the action i wish the
action had veered more
towards um sort of like jason bourne
type action like
like sort of visceral very close uh
quarters combat
i think that would have really really
made that uh yeah pop more
because they did some of that a little
bit of that then they transitioned
immediately to like marvel style
bombastic combat and
and scenes which were cool but i think
because she's not
a superhero per se he doesn't have
powers like that i think that sort of
combat would have really really
resonated more
but all in all like i said yeah i have i
have a new uh
crush
[Laughter]
i agree with you exactly any game sir
no games this week at all nothing at all
i've been working i've been hustling
it's been a crazy life they're probably
buying like
yeah yeah yeah um these super chats here
have you guys read them yet um
no no so you actually yeah there's no
one get those from yourself if you can
okay so we got an intro
uh flame two hours of chat also a big
recommended monster hunter stories two
yes then we got gerald mack five dollar
super chat lord cognito needs to put a
patent to put a patent on damn near
every word he says
we're working on it we're working on
we're on top of that
then we have silet bang 007 five pound
super jack hello to the lords i'm
repping my iopt while waiting to watch
england in the final come
on let's go let's get it nice get it
let's get it then we have flame once
again five dollar super chat
happy sunday everyone just wanted to say
it's been a fun week and welcome to the
royalty for the stream have a great show
guys hashtag
behaving we never do
uh then we got aseptima let's put the
crest in the chat because
remember the realm welcome lord bronze
aseptima thank you so much
i don't know if anything else popped up
that's it that's it
let's get it all right let's get it of
course we have the gaming ninja himself
the duke and shinobi
dude i did my theology on that well
that's
spreading the realness of the iop not
telling what you want to hear but what
you need to hear i'll make this quick
um happy born to everybody give a happy
birthday to my bro
ibontas it is oh happy birthday he's
very shy about
celebrating these things so we have to
do this we have to all
uh send out some love and tweet them out
directly you know i'm saying it's my
brother sorry i could not be there
friday
healing from this little ear allergy
thing but i'm on demand
i'm doing much better the pain is less
um yeah other than that man um
just i've been a little bit just
slightly gaming a little bit of destiny
salted
solstice uh mass effect 2 still on that
grind and i'm still ml beauty show
basically the same three games i've been
playing the last you know say a couple
of weeks or so but
anyway enough of that let's get into why
we are here
so um yeah we gotta focus on uh lord dan
the latest updates at play crafting the
indie game scene
and of course the triumphant physical
return
of play nyc convention in august so lord
dan
for those in the realm who are
completely unfamiliar to you maybe you
know new
like let the people know who dan butchco
is and what
exactly is play crafted sure so first
and foremost
like gaming is in my blood that is the
first thing i identify
with when it comes to anything related
to play crafting so like
fan first and foremost nice secondly
um yeah i head up play crafting so we
started way back in 2009 as a meetup
group
for local independent game developers
in new york city to connect with each
other show off what they're working on
knowledge share learn from each other
and it just kind of
grew and grew from there so now we're a
nationwide network
of independent game developers and we do
a whole lot of stuff we offer education
so folks that might want to
learn how to make games how to be
successful in the gaming industry
can do so through us uh we do tons and
tons of events
which we'll get into our biggest one
play nyc in a little bit
um and i think the coolest thing that
that's also the newest part of play
crafting
is that we found this really great way
to sort of match make
independent game developers solo
developers smaller studios
with huge brands so they can actually
make
games in partnership with big brands
like the nfl
verizon bose and it's been really really
cool to see
that that's that's generated a couple
million dollars now
for independent game developers to do
that kind of work with those huge
companies
so it's been it's a lot of stuff that
we're doing over at play crafting and i
think that uh
this particular time of year is by far
our busiest because
what i like to call our labor of love is
play nyc
and uh and i remember the first year we
launched it in 2017 it was like
all right we're signing up now for a
busy busy summer
from now until the end of eternity but
it's so worth it because new york needed
its own
all games convention and so that's what
we wanted to build and uh
and yeah this this year obviously it
feels a little weird it feels a little
bit like the first year because
we're coming back in person for the
first time since 2019
um but it just felt like it was going to
be such a missed opportunity if we
didn't have it
in august with everybody already
vaccinated
all the regulations in place it didn't
make sense for us to wait
another year and so we wanted to make
sure we were right at the forefront
and doing what we needed to do to make
sure we could do a really
safe and fun convention for folks
because this will be
the first time back for a lot of people
developers fans all
across the board yeah absolutely i mean
first of all love love what you're doing
in the indie game scene you know
providing those opportunities especially
what you said
in reference to the education part i
think that is really cool because
there's so many sides of game
development you know the education of
actually trying to make a game
you know the business side you know then
it's the promotion and the partnerships
and all these things involved and i love
two things that you do one
is that east coast focus because you
know i'm a little biased here it's that
it's the home team
and i i love that you know we you're
making
new york and the east coast you know
you're prioritizing those
in that area to at least attempt so that
because let's be honest dan right it's
always been told in the games industry
yo you got to go out to san francisco
or you got to go to washington you know
you can't do it in new york and things
like that i mean you've talked obviously
interviewed with you before
live with the show floor about the the
lack of what we
should say like tax breaks and things
that would help game developers kind of
be here now we do have something i think
we have
we have what uh take two we have um
avalanche yeah we have a few right but
yeah in general
you know to to to kind of make it a more
attractive thing so
the question my next follow-up question
to this is with that
being said in the new york thing and the
indie games seem like in general what
struggles are you seeing
from indie game developers as far as
just like trying to get their games out
or just
trends you may be noticing with up and
coming independent game developers
yeah i think the the hardest thing first
and foremost is that there are
hundreds and hundreds of games coming
out every single day and so it's really
hard for
independent developers to stand out
this is you know the the nature of game
development is is such that
all of us here now could make games
right now
for free and get started and so that
means that tons more people are making
games than ever before
so many more games are being released
than ever before so i think
the hardest part for a lot of
independent developers is to get their
games noticed
you look at the switch alone how many um
like
independent games come out on a weekly
basis so many of them you've never heard
of before
behind each of those games is one to
ten or more people who worked tirelessly
on those games and so
i think the sustainability is a really
challenging part because
a lot of folks will put their blood
sweat and tears into
a game and get it out there and a lot of
times if it doesn't hit
on that first one they may need to move
on to something else because they
need to pay the bills you know what i
mean so so i think that's probably
one of the biggest struggles um but you
know it takes that sort of
entrepreneurial new york like
can't stop won't stop attitude to keep
going
exactly i'm sure that was ingrained in
my head from like sixth grade
yeah yeah but yeah i think i think
that's probably the biggest struggle and
when it comes to new york there are a
few bigger companies here but
even with plan nyc a big part of why i
wanted to put it together and make it
happen was to show that
even without you know sony microsoft
nintendo
a huge collection of giant companies in
the games industry being here
there already are tons and tons of
smaller studios and solo developers that
are making
really cool interesting outside the box
content for all different kinds of uh
systems and so
even in the absence of that one thing
that you'll see at play nyc that's a
real reflection of new york city
itself is all of these great smaller
titles and
local multiplayer games that's what i
wanted to um
like to jump in on because yeah from
going to play nyc
uh play crafting i saw the diversity i
saw the melting pot which is new york
city
i saw the diversity in the games and in
the game genre it's
not just like like you know electronic
video games you know
stuff playing on the television i saw
board games i saw
uh you know people out there making
cardboard for labels and stuff like that
i saw virtual reality stuff it's it's
it was so diverse it was so
so intrinsically new york like
you you it's it felt like you was going
to the bronx and then you was going to
brooklyn and you was going to queens and
you were going to staten island
yeah right and you had different things
like the back scratch game was over here
if you can't make it to this place i
think you're really missing out
on the essence of what it means to be
like yeah boots on the ground ground
level stuff
like uh what what shocked the um the
sharknado uh not sharknado um
oh you mean swim
by the time they got to play nyc it was
a different energy it was like they had
the entire like
area to themselves and those fans
walking all around
yeah it was amazing it was a different
energy like we because we we first met
them attacks and we
do it and it was getting their teeth
together or whatever
but we we have an eye on it but when we
got to plan what
it was a different energy yeah you know
and
and then i think it gives that light to
the developer that they have this energy
please i had on virtual reality glasses
remember that i forgot about that yeah
it was
it's just so much great stuff that was
there that we can go into but
i just wanted to hearken in on the
diversity
of just different flavors just it's just
really collected really
fun stuff that was going on it was
beautiful if you guys want to see like
pure
unadulterated fun yes look at look at
our video of the kung fu kick
yes oh yeah yeah nyc yes they'll be back
this year too
shout out to it was it uh jonah yeah
jonah that game was so amazing so much
fun
um yeah it just like king said
in that small space there was such a
variety of games
that honestly like sometimes when you go
like a pax there's a lot a lot of games
but
yeah a lot can get lost in the shuffle
because you can't really address
everything
here it was intimate and everything
there
was so unique i don't think there were
really too many games that really
resembled one of them
yeah yeah man i that was so great that
was so great
no doubt no doubt so again just want to
follow up on that initial question again
about
how difficult it is to get a game and
how the struggles you know i'm saying
these services and these
dope things that you're providing you
know with play crafting but i want to
follow up because recently the big thing
and addictors
will know i'm going with this kind of
kind of came out in the in the indie
game
uh community shout out to uh leon you
know good friend of the realm
you know originally he was uh called
another indie uh now his
independent game uh publisher neon
doctrine and he he
put like a long twitter thread i don't
know if you get a chance to saw this um
then
basically you know talking about his
frustration with independent game
visibility
discounting on the on his game
communication with um
transparency on you know he called it
platform x but we all know it was
the sony storefront and i just wanted to
get your thought process on that thread
because it seemed to get a lot of
traction in the independent game
community a lot of developers are
speaking up saying they had similar
situations and not being able to get
visibility and discounting
and and the cost and all this other
stuff so you know
what what are your thought process when
you see threads like that
with maybe some frustration from
independent game developers
yeah i think there's a there's a lot of
um almost like predatory
behavior that can happen with like
certain smaller publishers and folks
that are
sort of positioning themselves as being
in the best interest of the independent
developer
but really are not and so you know it's
it's always heartbreaking for me to hear
about because a lot of times
especially in the independent game
development area when folks are getting
started or they're putting out
their first or second title they don't
really know what to look out
for and so they'll you know they'll
come across someone who says i will help
get you published onto these stores
um but they won't be totally transparent
around
you know what some of the practices are
on those storefronts or
or we'll have sort of like a revenue
share sort of model in place
that is definitely weighed against
the actual developer right and so a lot
of devs will come in and will
not know that that's not that's not best
practice that's not in their best
interest
right um and i think that really
educating
uh yourself is probably the the best way
to to go before you go into any of those
those scenarios what we see a lot at
play crafting is that
game developers themselves when we use
the word game developer we're talking
programmer
artist musician um designer like anyone
who
contributes to the actual build out of
the game we're not talking about like
marketer you know we're not talking
about like a pure business person
um and there can be really like a divide
between those two
types of folks in the world of games and
a lot of times with these
smaller independent studios um you know
it is just a programmer
and an artist and they don't have like a
pure business person because it's
just getting off the ground they don't
have like there's not there's not a
proof point there yeah you know what i
mean and so
it can be really challenging to sort of
navigate that without someone
on your side and so that's where i would
direct them to
places like play crafting the igda
um definitely you know look at some best
practices through
gdc the game developers conference
there's there's a lot of really great
places to kind of educate yourself as
you go in but
that is that is a challenge because when
you're super passionate and really
talented at building something and you
want to get it out there
like the it's it's hard to sort of turn
that off or dim that a little bit in
favor of making sure that your business
interests
are advocated for yeah no absolutely
fantastic point i mean i i think you you
nailed it as far as um
communication transparency as well as
far as trying to again
because it's one thing to you know as
far as best practice and doing the
correct thing to get
the visibility you need but then there's
another thing where you're on the
storefront and it's like
no one's responding to me like what kind
of scary
yeah like what do i do and then you have
this person has to then
go to other because of his connections
with other indie game devs hey
are you going through this are you
experiencing they're like yeah we're
stuck and we just
we just want to discount our game and we
just want to know what the you know
the what we do with visibility i'm sorry
dad you're about to jump in
i thought somebody's going to jump sorry
no no i was going to go into it a little
bit more but you you know you hit the
points on okay
i just felt that uh when you are going
into a partnership and a lot of these
guys are
new going into these partnerships they
stay
have different expectations they don't
know uh
going through that okay you're gonna
give your 25 grand or whatever it is and
you think okay
that's going to be valued because i'm
going to be valued
right and that's all they want to be
they want to be valued and heard
or given some form of direction on how
can my uh
game get uh seen yeah how do i get a
liaison to uh help me uh with this i
have a problem here
oh when is the proper time for me to do
a discount
yeah if you're not being heard and
the level of frustration starts to ramp
up with
you had different expectations going in
and then also compounded with the fact
that you actually paid
your money because yeah and then
percentage of the cut on top of the
money
yeah that's that's a big thing too you
know dan is telling you
put your developer side to the side
first and put your business hat on
right because you have to have on your
business hat and you have to have on
your eyes you have to have your
your t's uh uh uh crossed and your eyes
dotted
going into these situations and know
exactly what your percentage is
what is exactly going on on the business
end of it
because the frustration part the
frustrating part
besides the logistics of getting your
game seen
because a lot of times it hits the store
and you don't even know it's
there unless you can search for how can
you search for something that you don't
know is there you would literally have
to the way lee and expect like you would
literally have to search for his game
because
again like king you're making some fire
points it's the competition on the
storefront
right it's so large you have all these
bigger games and
you know attic you you know i mean you
you know liam person you're the one that
kind of
introduced us i remember being at our
first packs and and meeting him and you
really taking a liking to his games at
the time he was another indie
you know we felt those games punched
about his weight punch above their
weight so
like attic like what do you think in
reference to that whole fighting for
visibility thing
i think when it comes down to it it's
like you know
it's it's just it's just like dan said
yeah
business in the developer side of total
two different things like
look at the end of the day i i do think
sony at the very least needs to hire
more people in that department
actually not necessarily probably i
don't know maybe
those people are temp agents or
something like you know maybe
it's hard to tell the the turnaround
that's in that company that probably
didn't wasn't trained properly because
like something has to be
wrong that you know you have multiple
money yeah
you can put the money aside but
something had to be wrong where
how do you not know your own process
like right
like and that's the issue i had it's not
it wasn't the money it was anything it's
like
you're there to help people yeah and i
feel like if you're not helping people
what are you doing are you just
answering phones
diverting the conversation because like
when i worked at
i i used to work at a call center like
the pro
like that what they would call that is
like uh they would call that
uh shorting your callback like you have
to
if you if you do it right the first time
sony guess what
they don't call back yeah
but i think there's multiple broken
links in this chain right right and it's
uh
the communication part uh maybe it's a
staffing
part like addict you know alluded to but
ultimately it's how do you know the
process to get into the carousel
for your game to be seen right the
visibility part
that's the that's the biggest part for
any type of developer
the visibility part because
like i said when you turn on your xbox
you turn on your playstation you turn on
your switch
and you go to the store right nine times
out of ten you're looking at the big
stuff that's that's that you
know it's there right right and if
something happens to pop up on the ad
down at the bottom
what's that what's that yeah how did he
get there
right how can my game gets to to where
he's at so
what's that can happen to millions of
people
that happen to turn on their their
console right and
the frustrating part is they don't have
an answer
to how your stuff get into the carousel
to be seen and no that's the that's the
biggest problem the communication
with the developer on getting that part
done yeah no absolutely absolutely this
is a good discussion and again we
appreciate
you know what dan is doing with play
crafting because oh yes you know
this education and and having that
network and building that independent
game
community right you know to learn you
know
i guess i guess you could tell us dan
like you know is it more of a
collection of thoughts and ideas between
the devs and saying hey these are our
experiences
these are some things you can do like
you know do you guys
comment and work with the devs in that
particular fashion when they're having
these frustrations
yeah i think we really handle it on like
a case-by-case basis for us
in terms of like what we're doing on a
regular basis
um the work that i mentioned we we do
with the nfl verizon bose
niantic is a really awesome partner we
just started working with
pokemon go folks yeah yeah um so i think
a
a big part of what we do in that process
and something i love about it is
that like there are so many great ways
where these larger companies and smaller
companies can work together
so that both of their interests are
being met their goals are being met and
both are being
are succeeding and so that's where with
a company like verizon or bose or nfl or
niantic
we are sort of like that intermediary
throughout the process
and so um we address things like if
there's a concern about the contract
if there's a a concern on like the
business side of things
we are working with developers all
throughout that process to make sure
that
you know they're being properly paid
they're being
their needs are being met that the the
brand and the partner that we have in
place that their goals are being met
because
these are like two puzzle pieces that
sometimes
don't fit together but really should fit
well together because when they fit well
together
new games are generated that otherwise
wouldn't have been before
players and fans get to try out new
things and new technologies that they
wouldn't have before
so it's just there's such a great
win-win
uh scenario there when in our case
we are like the the intermediary between
the two and we're able to make sure that
both are being are are you know being
addressed and being helped along the
process
nice nice good stuff good stuff good to
hear and like i said it's a great
resource
for the independent game scene but i
want to transition forward on
that play nyc man you know returning
returning in the physical form you know
obviously the lords were there 2019 we
had an
absolute ball you know what i mean and
uh for those who kind of want
info on the event and what to expect
from
on player nyc 2021 like you know first
that's the first was like what to expect
and then the second part is like
what experiences did you learn from the
all
virtual event the prior year coming in
to this one
yeah so um let's start with the the
second question
so um 2020 obviously you know we were
completely virtual
and um we we had the venue
all set we already announced play nyc
2020.
um but it did we had to do a virtual
thing there was just
no way in which we were doing nothing
throughout 2020
and i think that like there were really
two things that really stuck out
number one was that the virtual
component allowed us to have
developers and games from around the
world represented who may not
necessarily be able to make it
to new york specifically
we also had it completely free to attend
and also to exhibit
last year so that also sort of lowered
the barrier for entry
um and then the other piece on in 2020
that we really grew out was our graffiti
games initiative where
we commissioned developers from
underrepresented communities
to make games that debut at the show and
so
that was at the yeah that was at the
height of the george floyd protests and
everything last summer and so
last year we focused on amplifying the
voices of black developers and really
leaned into it
and it was really a like a standout
piece of play nyc
um graffiti games always is but
particularly last year and i think that
like
as we're now in 2021 um you know
given that it was all virtual and that
we did have it free to
attend even for exhibitors we put some
things into place
so that uh even more developers can
participate this year
so we have like a needs-based
application on our site for developers
that may not be able to afford an
exhibitor spot and so
larger companies have bought out like
like smaller booths
that are basically sponsoring smaller
companies and
local developers yeah wonderful so that
was one lesson learned i think that
that translated really well we really
use that opportunity to to um like
just enhance and enliven our stream
because we did have a stream all
throughout last year's and so
this year's stream is going to be higher
production
we still we're stepping up in a lot of
ways when it comes to the stream because
um a lot of people can't make it out to
the show and so
our stream is on a stage in the middle
of the show floor
for a reason we wanted to feel
integrated into the overall experience
for people that are there
but also for people that can't be there
to feel like they are integrated into
the show floor itself too and so that
was another lesson
um and then because of graffiti games
last year just being
such a such a powerful moment we've
built it out even more it's now an
annualized
program um we've had rockstar games join
us
which is really cool oh yes that's a
flex sir we're gonna let you
just dance past that rockstar is in the
building y'all
yeah yeah yeah yeah so they've been
really great to work with on the
graffiti games side of things
and we've turned it into more of an
annualized program um
and in terms of what to expect you know
this is i i said before this is the
first time
that a lot of people will be at a gaming
convention together
in a long time and with that comes a lot
of excitement and responsibility at the
same time and so it
it felt like this was not the year to
try some like
off-the-wall crazy you know
this was the year to take what worked
really well in 2019 which was our
biggest most successful one yet
yeah and do that again but obviously
with all the
the covid requirements and safety
precautions
put into place yeah so how do how does
one
uh get into play and why
i i really need to know uh because i
already know what i have to do this week
i have to go get chip
i need to go get my internal gps
the question is you know all joker
decide though what uh
what what do people need to have in
place in order to
uh gain entry but you know to
play and why yeah so we're like straight
up we're requiring vaccination
for everyone that's there so if you're
um
staffing the event showing at the event
you're a press person
or a general attendee vaccinations
required um
the one exception we're making is for uh
children under 12 in which we're
accepting
um proof of covet negative like a
negative
test result from the previous 48 hours
that's you all were there before so it's
not like a children's event but we
wanted to make sure that
um you know the few parents that do
bring their kids can can do so again but
safely
um so yeah that's really the main thing
um
you need to provide proof of full
vaccination and a photo id
at the entrance and then
that's i mean that's pretty much it
we've done a lot of other things to make
sure that
you know inside the venue folks are
comfortable because
you know we want to assume here that you
know many people even though they're
fully vaccinated
may not want to be like completely
shoulder to shoulder
with a bunch of strangers yeah so we've
done a bunch of stuff to make sure that
the
um like the walkways are much wider than
they even were in 2019
we opened up another exit so that people
can walk out and in a couple of
different ways
yeah so so i think all that stuff was
was probably
like like the first month of planning
that was where we were really um ironing
all those things out ironing
i like that yeah lloyd's reference yeah
those bars once we did that you know
i we made the announcement i think in
late april that it was going to be
live and in person again yeah and that
was before we started talking to
fans and players that would want to be
there exhibitors that would want to be
there
so developers who want to show their
games when we first announced it it was
like okay things are going in the right
direction
the regulations are falling into place
let's do this
but i was still obviously like okay is
everybody going to be
super nervous and not want to do
anything for a few months
um but it wasn't until i and the rest of
the team started talking to developers
looking to show their games that it was
really confirmed that it's it's the
right time
to come back because now we have i think
over 60 games or so that are confirmed
for the the show floor so far
yeah and folks are really really excited
to
get their games and in the hands of
players and
and fans are excited to to come through
and play so once those conversations
started happening i i knew it was going
to be
it was the right decision yeah i just
want to follow up on king's
point because you know in reference to
you know obviously the pandemic and
you know again shout out to to you guys
you know just taking that responsible
stance on it you know
and correct me if i'm wrong like that
you you will be
play nyc will be the first gaming
convention
opened physical in person event during
the pandemic correct
i i think in north america yeah north
america yeah you guys are the first
so you know again salute to you guys
take the responsibility
making the requirements and stuff like
that now in contrast again i don't want
to throw
packs under the bus obviously we have a
lot of great
relationships with pax pax east the
lords made their bones at pax east
but we did see you know initially they
said it was west was returning
but we didn't necessarily see the covid
vaccination requirement and there seems
to be a lot of conflict there people who
were once saying that they were going to
go
now they're saying they might not go as
a result you know and
what's your thought process as we try to
get back to the new normal
you know with with this whole you know
some may do it and some may not do it
you know
in reference to the vaccination
requirement yeah i think that we're
really fortunate with play nyc
where first of all as everybody knows
new york was the center of the pandemic
in the beginning but but just like it
was the center of the pandemic in the
beginning it's also
kind of been the center of the reopening
and having the
um regulations and like the the real
guidelines for events to
to come back and so we've been really
fortunate in terms of
the location in our hometown being
really sort of
ahead of the curve when it comes to what
it would take
to come back and also you know while
playing nyc
is big and awesome and we have a blast
with it it is
5 000 people as opposed to 80 000 plus
people yeah um and so we're able to make
you know decisions like very quickly
we're a team of
four full-timers behind the scenes um
the the process of like being able to
get the engine
up and going and do so safely and and
make sure that we have everybody covered
was really
easy i'm sure by comparison to like an
80 000 plus
show but i would say that like the
biggest lesson that i learned and i've
been thinking about it a lot when it
comes to pax is that
in this particular time when you
announce your event
like what what really matters is like
where people's heads are at
at the time of announcement and not when
it's happening
right you know what i mean because this
this whole year and a half during the
pandemic has really forced
everybody for a lot of reasons to take
things one day at a time
one step at a time like there was there
was no way to travel
anywhere for a long time there was no
way to go to anything for a long time
so it's hard for folks to make a
decision about going to something
two three months from now with no
vaccination requirement
right hey we might be at like 25 events
between now and then and feel like
okay like i'm ready for that kind of
thing but you have to kind of make the
announcement and set those regulations
based on based on where people are at
exactly right now um and
and that's where i think some of that
disconnect is is coming into play got
you yeah
it was it was a touch and go subject for
uh cog and i
because he understood how adverse i was
to
being vaccinated being you know chipped
and i mean it was it was a point of
contention because you know we had those
conversations in my household
and uh it boiled down to
uh how i feel about what we're doing at
iron lords llc
um it boiled down to uh
how i feel about the community uh what
my
my vision for what we
do and and not not elevating
out my thoughts in what we are
i believe that we're important and i
believe we're important for
one reason i don't believe there's
anybody that works harder than us
on the floor talking to devs getting
their voice out
i don't believe so and i believe if
we are not present doing that
then we are taking that voice away
from the public and that
is when i made my decision to yeah okay
yeah um i i i have to and i have to be
present i have to show up
and i have to be accountable and at some
point in time
you have to say to yourself uh if it's
uh for the
benefit of the group and when i say the
group i mean the herd i mean everyone
who's at
play nyc right you know because
everybody i play nyc has made this
choice true uh to be there for the
benefit
of everyone else it's each man teach one
each one the next
person is responsible for the next
person that's standing next to them
and maybe you don't want to be this
close and you know you have that
proximity space or whatever because
you're just getting back to that norm
because we are used to social distancing
now
right but you can go into that place
with a clear mind knowing that that
person went through the
same eternal struggle by going to get
vaccinated and he's making
he or she is making that same commitment
that you did
by being there so uh that's when i was
like it's a no-brainer
it's absolute respect going through i
couldn't wait
for this show in particular to tell you
that i respect
you that much i respect what you're
doing that much
that you know i feel that yes i am with
you
standing hand by hand side by side in
this journey going in i know that
decision to say
we're going to be vaccinated and people
might have a opposing opinions to that
but you had to stand
firm in your beliefs and keeping people
safe
and i think that meant more than
anything else
yeah no absolutely oh sorry sorry for
you considering no no me because you you
know my initial reaction when
when you first put into our uh our chat
that fanway he's coming back my initial
reaction was like now i'm good till next
year
and i'm vaccinated from like
yeah so um but
hearing dan talk now i think i didn't
know what i
had no idea what you know the protocols
would be or not
hearing what you're doing and what
you're requiring at the door
is is heartening and like king said it
you're doing everything in your power to
make sure that you're not bringing this
event back to to an empty like
you know a hollow empty room yeah and
i think that's amazing because again the
the thing the issue that i have
is that as soon as regulations started
sort of started to sort of soften a
little bit
the problem is oftentimes obviously if
you're a person is vaccinated and you've
gone into all this trouble when you're
going through this
this trial and tribulation of do i do i
not um you want to be able to have that
moment where you can take your mask off
and say hey i feel comfortable i feel
safe
the problem is that oftentimes people
who are their a
irresponsible about their health and
other people's health
or people who again like king had
reservations
about doing it but for whatever reason
say hey
everyone else is doing it here i am
i'm like so it's a lack of trust in
other people's
you know ability to do the right thing
yeah but again
i think what you're doing is great and
uh i will be there oh
did you hear this
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
hold on creeper evox in the chassis that
came out yeah i'm burnt up man
i'm crispy as well right yeah
that puerto rican chip man he didn't
bring the parakeet back with him
[Laughter]
my wife just bent over laughing when i
told her that the parakeet made an
appearance on the show
we had an iop exclusive
the parakeet was not feeling the
treatment of indie devs by playstation
great great discussion in reference to
the you know the pandemic stuff like
that i want to i want to get back to
playlist for one more thing i just
wanted to um
i'm looking at that confirmed list lord
dan and um
you got you got our good friends from
boston uh
decoy games shout out to us a khalid
avec
yes you don't say you got the hometown
whale food games that kung fu kickball
shout out to
jonah you know what i'm saying and more
recently i
gotta i gotta salute you on this one um
avalanche studios
hello so yeah recently had the big
announcement on the uh microsoft but
that's the e3 stage i know they they
showcased their contraband
but they've got tremendous lineage was
it just cause and
that's right so mad max
yeah so tell us about that what other
partners or studios can we expect but
yeah
that was a big flex there what's going
on yeah well that's that's again where
the real like hometown thing comes into
play because avalanche has been
with us i think since the beginning and
they
love making sure that like they are
there to showcase that new york has
a vibrant community and network of
game developers and studios and so it
would have felt like something was
missing if if avalanche wasn't back with
us this year
yeah yeah um so yeah you forget they had
that
like when you get to them yeah yeah yeah
i forgot about this yeah it's right when
you walk in it's almost right when you
know what it is
was it was it more in the center it was
more in the center yeah again
yeah yeah it's you straight down and
behind the uh the the ear thing the the
vr everything
okay right but how close of proximity
was it towards because remember
yeah like a red bull ea thing it was
right across from the
from the red bull right right i drink so
many redwoods
what's so cool about player yc like we
said we're discussing this right we
remember
like you've got the all these you know
big guys you got the smaller developers
around you got the independent scene you
got the table top
like is is new york city coming together
and what i like it doesn't matter if
you're big or you're small they're like
literally side by side in that space
love what you're doing on that setup
brother yeah really cool and i i feel
like
like something i love about playing nyc
you know a lot of times even as
gamers and as fans we kind of fall into
our own little
sort of silos and our own little boxes
so you'll have like your
your like frat boy like fifa
fan you know what i mean and then you'll
have your like your group who likes like
more
more artistic games and to me it's like
the cool thing about
gaming is that there are so many
different kinds of games for so many
different kinds of people
and new york is already such a great
sort of beacon
of diversity and inclusivity as as a
people
that i wanted to make sure that not only
is that represented
in who's actually attending play nyc and
playing together
but the games that are there and putting
red bull right next to
kung fu kickball you know what i mean
like that that's what's so
cool and weird and random about gaming
as a whole it's not
just one thing anymore um and so i'm
excited to sort of see
the 2021 version of that come back again
this year because that's really
you know it's the uniting power of video
games and playing together
that i think is so special and being
able to have play nyc as sort of like a
representation of that even on the
physical show floor is really important
yeah no absolutely i was really shocked
at
how many virtual reality options
that you had there you had
to be honest you had a little bit more
virtual reality options than some of the
bigger guys
i and i was like wow he actually took a
slice out because
i mean that stuff means a lot to me uh
so
when and it was it was so diverse like
okay so
those those glasses because the bose
ones yeah the bulls glasses
that stuff was so unique that i didn't
see it no place else
you know and i was i was like yo we have
to remember the game that was playing
and you had to bop your head
oh yeah yeah
go and watch these videos because these
videos are so intense and so great
because when you find something that you
actually love and you get a chance to
talk to the dev about it and the dev is
actually jazzed up too about it
and they're talking about it and you
have that back and forth and you're
getting great content
um i just i just found it because it
happened in a lot of
moments so all i can do is just think
back with a lot of fun moments it really
wasn't any dull
spots there as we hit the floor because
some spots where you
didn't think that you would be like
intrigued by
the cardboard label stuff that's when i
knew label was for real
yeah yeah at that point because when he
was like playing the piano and stuff
like that you know you think it's a
gimmick on tv
or stuff like that or a nintendo stage
situation
but this was live in front of me yeah
yeah
wasn't staged it was out in the open and
anything could go wrong and it was like
spot-on and i'm like oh this lava thing
on my apple
dude yeah it's really nice stuff it's
just a lot of smile
moments and it's just really nice stuff
yeah definitely
one of our highlights you know like i
said absolute pleasure i got a chance to
interview on
on the floor you know saw had some great
interviews with like i said decoy with
uh kung fu up being high playing and
getting rambunctious there were a lot
man there was so many cool
unique games we're looking forward to
getting back to that so love that you're
pioneering
getting back out there in a physical
event we the the lords will be there
three deep now you know
yes so it'll be cool to see and i just
want to wrap up as far as
last time you were here um we had our
vintage top five video games of all time
so
this was iop 127 and um at the time you
said uh
your five consistent probably of three
zelda games yep
that's what i said so we we tried to
nail that down between or is it a
skyward sword breath of the wild ocarina
of time you said that three
rotates just before we get into the rest
of the list
are we still hard and fast with that
those three zelda games and though
and their ranking and their positionings
yes okay cool
so now the other four
hell struggle that i like he ain't let
go that scout was so i respect it
so um what i wanted to say is you had
four others which were
like the realm was in love with you just
wouldn't know if any there were any
changes since
at the time you had journey yeah wwf no
mercy
batman arcane cube city and portal
has that list retained in your top five
i'm going to pull it up right now
last updated july 9th
i like that okay okay yeah all right so
we we are retaining that list
all right let me see let's see in my top
10 it looks like all right one game
[Music]
cycled out and one game cycled in oh
which one
so bioshock moved to number 11. oh okay
okay
and a new entry is at number nine and
that's animal crossing new horizons oh
yes yes yes and it's it's for a very
specific reason like a lot of these
games i have
it's not just i'm not going into it with
like a reviewer
mindset a lot of it is my personal
experience with it and if i have like a
specific memory
attached to it and as i mentioned at the
top of the show like
animal crossing new horizons me and my
parents we shared an island
all throughout the pandemic religiously
it was i will ne that is now one of my
favorite
gaming memories of all time and like
when they unlocked the um
uh like going diving i remember my mom
has not like
gone diving like on a beach in years and
she was just like hearing her so excited
to be able to
go diving in her like little cartoon
swimsuit like
you know what i mean yeah yeah
so so that's why animal crossing is now
so
so high when i'm if i were to look at
this as like a like a pure
reviewer standpoint it's like maybe i'd
look at things differently but
my it's my list and it's about the
memories and that's why skyward sword is
so high up there because
that one-to-one wii motion plus
worked spot-on for me
was unmatched i have not had any
experience
like that since addict uh
you hear this man it's a lot let me
let's get this poll
together how do i make a poll
it's next to that i think it's on the
bottom to the left next to this other
smiley face
yeah are you going to do it make sure
eric does not
bias this ball yeah the option will be
skyward sword
if we can get uh let me see how much we
have 370 people here
um if we can get 250 likes
uh we can get attic to play sky woods oh
that's what we do
yes you really trying to get this
i think i think this switch is gonna
take that one to one ratio
to the next level
yo trust me when i tell you i'm so happy
that i didn't buy a standstill
i'm so happy
that's brand new in the box so i don't
have any drifting so
yeah and i can uh
wait there's 16
doing physical and digital okay what
about isn't there like special joy-cons
and
there's like a whole bunch of updates
and stuff with this with uh
so y'all doing that oh kig are you doing
the amiibo sir
oh of course hell yeah yeah
that they have okay so this is some
controversy we literally transitioned
right into it
right yeah yeah the controversy behind
it is they said that the
like there's a trend a traversal in the
game that is locked behind
the amiibo if you don't have this amiibo
you can't do a certain traversal
in the game yeah and i don't care same i
don't care either
it's just fast it's fast travel right
yeah it's the quality of life things
oh so so if you don't want the quality
of your life
are we implying that it's a you problem
yes
[Laughter]
go ahead and vote on what's the best
zelda game in the chat oh that's not the
problem
this man literally was the best
narrative
what's the best zelda game ocarina of
time breath of the wild twilight
princess
breath of the wild there's no scouting
mission
[Laughter]
hey clearly clearly somebody agrees with
us if they're promoting
breath of the wild 2 with people
dropping out of the sky
i mean there's we're not alone nintendo
i think agrees with us and they're like
wait a minute
skyward sword was so much better than
people gave it credit for we're going to
re-release it
and we're going to make a huge sky
component in breath of the wild too it's
interesting like all jokes are
significant because i've never played
the game never seen the game
and it's interesting because i didn't
know skyward sword kind of brought a lot
of those mechanics that breath of the
wild uses like the gliding
and other stuff so it will be
interesting to see you know i
for me i'll be honest with y'all got me
well i am going to pick it up
is i'm a big master sword guy so when
addict told me
yo that's the history of like the map
this is the beginning of the timeline
yeah like i i i like that i do want to
know
what's going on with that and um
obviously to control motion control
stuff like that but solve is it is it
optional or correct if i'm wrong is
there something can you not
play i will be playing with my i will be
playing with my plural controller thank
you very much
you can literally play it without it
yeah yes yeah because
all right so this is the thing is this
is where um
nintendo had pigeoned themself into a
hole okay
by making the stand still all the light
all right so
yeah the reason why i call it a stance
though because the the whole
thought concept behind the switch was
you can switch from playing it docked
you can switch from playing it uh
portable you can switch from playing
with your controller aren't locked onto
the screen you can
snap them off and switch into playing
into dual mode you can switch by having
your friends so the whole concept behind
switch was switching
your game style to fit
your needs at the moment so when they
made the standstill
you literally took away what made the
switch
you can't call it switch anymore yeah
yeah that
to get the purists out of it i think
they're going because it was one to one
it was
i think that was the first time i
actually got a video game because you
had the nunchuck and he was able to do
the shield here and the sword here
and i just it just felt so liberating
because i always wanted to do that in a
zelda game
from the moment i did play uh a link to
the past
uh or or or any type of zelda game even
on my game boy i always wanted to be
able to
swing that sword or use the shield to
block
and you can move it up and down to block
high
black mid and block low it was a lot of
thought that went into it and i didn't
think he got its recognition but i
really loved it and the fact that
nintendo recognized what
me and dan both feels yeah
we're trailblazers clearly yeah just
what it really
did i mean to be honest it's been like
it feels like 15 years and they still
haven't made a metro collection
like you know so yeah let's see here act
like the title makes the greatest
decisions in the world
we can't sit here and do nothing all
year long but look down on what nintendo
does in terms of its
fan base and then the one time it's it
fits your narrative to act like they
make it hard
definition of a fanboy i'm unapologetic
about an apologetic family
we're gonna put a real poll up there to
get attic to play this game
that's 250 likes because you're wrong
the community votes for us to do things
like the community voted for me to get a
tattoo on my chest
and the community voted
[Laughter]
you know that there is that that paul is
in the chat so definitely go
oh there's a new poll down let's see how
biased it is to the hell with that poll
um there's still a skyward sword is
there okay okay
it's there but it's not exactly okay
okay
it needs to be the first option yeah
yeah
now we have like a visual representation
of how idiots you got
oh my god oh my god ridiculous 19
okay first off i'm a little upset that
skyward swords over twilight princess
but
it is what it is man breasts of the wild
and all created time are beating the
sky roots okay well we're not looking
for what is the best zelda that's
subject to
like what period you were born in uh but
again
we are looking for you to play together
anyway you're afraid hold on no no we're
going to address this
are you afraid that you might play it
and actually
might like it imagine the magic
imagine if you come away
yeah yeah i'd rather take uh uh
toothpicks to my eyeballs oh my gosh
so let's say let's say let's say i how
about i dear you
oh like like what can i do what are we
doing we in the third grade
sometimes some people take dares very
seriously
i don't know i don't know what's your
trigger to get you to play this game
but no he's gonna play he said he's
gonna play it no he said he's gonna play
no he's gonna play it we're gonna play
the lords will make that happen
he's gonna play no no he's playing it he
did say that he gave me his
words like yo i'll play it it's all good
because he said he can't talk
reckless the way he's been talking and
especially there's been
so long since he did play it you know
the memories and stuff like that and
the new coat of paint right lord dan
like we gotta say
it might take me a couple years but
it'll get played no
don't worry about that dan i i really
had hope
because i really hoped that we'd been on
the show today and we'd had our zeldas
in our hands
he literally said real quickly oh lord i
forgot to ask you this last time you
were here we didn't do
um favorite console of all time
oh easy gamecube yeah yeah let's talk
about it
150 gamecube yeah i think i um
so when gamecube came out that was 2001
i was 16 and it was the first
it was the first console that i like
followed all the way up until release
got it on release day
bought it with my money you know what i
mean like i felt ownership over it
yeah and then i there were just so many
great games on there and i think a big
part of it was because
gamecube was like where switch was at
the beginning where it was like nintendo
with its back against the wall
and so they were doing more like weird
outside the box things
so that's that's where you got metroid
prime in there
you got wind waker eternal darkness
which
needs to come back oh my god yeah that's
the one that i wish i could have fit in
that pose
is win-win
i went real deep on like b-sides and
deep cuts when it came to that system
like
there was a game called cubivore if you
remember yeah i really
enjoyed a game it was called gotcha
force on that i really
yeah yeah yeah yeah gamecube love
atticus
super monkey ball two oh my god all the
time
yeah i was in college and that was one
of those games where i played it for so
many hours on end that i would go to
sleep and i would close my eyes and i
would go through the entire
like every course in my brain because i
knew exactly
like what what you had to avoid what the
exact route was on the path
to win every time
and it had a handle on it yeah come on
like a little lunch it was purple had a
handle wasn't trying to be
like anything but like a video game
concert
you know those smaller discs i remember
it yeah
those little baby discs yeah rogue rogue
squad
no doubt that tremendous list all that
we could talk gaming forever let's get
into these topics but what i'm going to
do is solve i'll get
i want to point out that um you know
it's a really important thing that i
feel like needs to be brought up
[Laughter]
okay okay until after you play it you
let me know
[Laughter]
you know something he's gonna hit me at
three o'clock in the morning he was
right and just hang up the phone yeah
yeah yeah yeah
don't say nothing i'm gonna hit you at
three o'clock somewhere like you know
anyone that wants to buy skyrocketing oh
my god
unopened
anyway let's get into this phone that we
got on top of that i definitely want to
get uh
that no daddy so last week results are
in and the people have
spoken with the recent announcement of
gosham's director's cut adding a brand
new island to
explore and multiple ps5 specific
updates do you have
any issue with the way it is financially
being handled as an upgrade
the winner at 55 well actually it wasn't
i got the percentages wrong
these are actually incorrect so i'm just
gonna say the winner in place the winner
of the vote
was yes they are charging for basic
fixes
haptic feedback and upscale when other
platforms offer these things for free
coming in at second place was the messy
laws i don't care it's all fun and games
until
big ghost drops in august then we're
gonna see if you gamers are gonna hold
the
line in last place was i have no issue
it's essentially an
ultimate edition with multiple new
features group so uh shout out to all
the lords who participated in last
week's poll
lord attic you're very passionate about
this subject last week uh you seem to be
victorious in the poll your people have
agreed
obviously
i knew the moment the poll went up i was
winning
[Laughter]
no doubt we're going to get into a song
if you could do it we got a lot of super
chat let's catch up with the super chat
we'll jump into that uh
switch i'm gonna i'm gonna change that
poll here in a couple minutes
no doubt if you can get those super
chats ready uh we got
uh asepta once again with the 50 super
chat thank you so much sir
salutations to the lords just got my
series x and college acceptance at the
same
day i couldn't be more excited keep up
the top tier content have a good one and
god bless congratulations sir
congratulations
doubt then we have antoine williams two
dollar super chat
take out money would you take that space
flight
take out take out the money issue would
you take a space flight no
ah man i don't know
[Music]
good food off the grill and loads of
gaming ice cube was right today
is good day oh classic cube classic
respect then we got tony bryant five
dollars
happy sunday everyone these are absolute
gems dan is dropping make sure to like
and share this
out to people yes 100 for sure for sure
then we got gerald mack five dollar
super chat lord kingstradamus and lord
sovereign
rocking the salt and pepper beards
wrapping the oats
listen my judgment is upstairs i'm still
celebrating
my birthday i brought mine too for you i
have a couple in there
congratulations on the epic beard sir
it's funny i went back
i went back to our video of cogs
interviews
you're looking very young i'm sure i was
like a toddler back then
i'm now 45 years older than i was two
years ago three years ago
by the time this show was over half an
hour from now i will it will look like
my shirt
[Laughter]
little by little he's just brushing it
shout out to that og beard talk
what else we got with the peach fuzz
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
we got cloud real quick christopher hart
says people
vote breath of the wild before adam gets
a chance to change the
the votes what else we get
oh no there's look at that the big cloud
gave me five clown
what's good lord salute hope you're
feeling better cog oh i think yeah on
the man on the man thank you
then we got raider blade 10 super 10
pound super chat hello lords good
evening from the uk
have a great one just stopping by to get
my support hit that like button oh yes
please hit that like much appreciate it
thank you
then we have [ __ ] five dollar super
chat nintendo will make a pro model
because that means more triple a
competition can be on their platform
taking sales away from their first party
i wouldn't doubt that that is part of
the plan that is
not the plan not the plan
we will we will give them so we can
shine
ridiculous good point ridiculous what
else you guys want
we have raider blade again 10 power
super chat cog
what days do the dukes run and is it
clean or do we have
f-bombs i only ask because it depends on
the time i might be at work it might be
inappropriate
sharing it and not your viewer
uh well the lord i i still act lordly
in the realm of the duke so you know
what but the dukes do
is what the dukes do yeah like i said
shout out to last fb like i said
i don't put anyone you know underneath
my rule set you know say that's just
something that
the way the lord carries something but i
will say i will say
cog has a cleansing effect i have i've
heard less f-bombs
as a result that is true yeah i think i
think even colin bet you did you
say yeah i don't know what it is it's a
um
it's an unconscious thing yeah if if
you're around people that
are they're curbing their language yeah
uh
you will do it it just will be
automatically because you
won't hear that type of verbage so your
verbage will change to match the
verbiage of yeah
but no doubt like i said that cog
doesn't put any restrictions on anyone
else's
just me and in the realm i would say
yeah headphones are advisable just yes
yes yes just in case
okay uh we're good we're caught up no
doubt and
joining us the lady of the realm
scum cast his own amazing luca how are
we doing sis
hello gentlemen thanks so much for
having me
here told you yeah yeah guys
ladies and gentlemen it's been a minute
how you've been what's been going on
with you very quickly how
[ __ ] makes it seem like someone just
snuck in it's a big surprise
that's how it makes it feel wrong
like i didn't know this was gonna happen
voice
did i hear me and everything yeah
yeah things are great man thanks so much
for having me i
always love hanging out with my boys you
know hanging out in the room at least i
know that uh king david is someone i can
rely on for these raids but whatever and
you're like
oh smoke come for me she comes because
i don't know what it is she right she's
like what's once i got vex with the
class i kind of
okay
i got what i came for i'm good
i got hollywood i'll be back though it's
good to be here thanks so much for
having me
no doubt no doubt look at him run but
let's get to these topics so a big one
i know um attic wanted to talk about
this uh yeah it looks like uh the
nintendo switch uh
dropped the new device there uh switch
oled
you know goes on sale october 8th for
350 dollars
a lot of um don't say controversy
regarding it but there were definitely
some polarizing opinions
on the level of what was being offered
so it looks like there's gonna be a
larger seven
inch 720p oled screen um there will be
uh excuse me a built-in ethernet port
obviously the
built-in storage goes up from 32 gigs to
64.
and uh yeah so you know there was you're
gonna miss the the most important
feature i'm sorry please please
please remind me sir the wide stand
yes yes i was waiting for it i was
waiting for it
to be honest with you like i do
appreciate that white stand
okay okay well look this is this is
definitely addict's topic you know you
wanted to bring this to the realm
so let adam you may have a surprising
viewpoint on this right what's your
thought process on the oled
switch release i think that you know if
if you've picked up every iteration of
the switch and i think if you were
believing uh
the uh quote-unquote insiders on the
internet talking about
a 4k device which you can you can go uh
on the
iron lords podcast there's multiple
episodes where i said you guys are full
of it and you
hyping yourself too much up for this and
this is probably just going to be an old
lead screen
and it's going to have no performance
enhancement whatsoever
and then i've had multiple times where
multiple lords said there's no way
[Laughter]
now we're on that situation to where
it's exactly what they're going to do
you probably disappointed me for this
but for
for people such as myself that only
played this on a handheld device i never
i don't even know where my dock is i
forgot that thing goes on your tv wow
and i haven't upgraded a switch since
the very first
uh switch back in 2017 i didn't get the
iteration i get none of that light stuff
or uh
what do you call that king
still by the stand still like this is
it's definitely something i
consider picking up because i need a new
upgrade and i'd be stupid not to get the
oled
switch like so it's like nothing i'm
probably gonna do day one but you know
when they drop something like you know
breath of the wild two or something
it's something i'll probably pick up
just for that obviously
you know people are saying oh you know
performance this performance that look
i've always been the person that i
bought this for their first party stuff
i've said it over and over again
i don't care about no doom eternal i
don't care about no wolfenstein
i don't even care about a lot of the
indie games on there i literally picked
this
up to play breath of the wild it was
literally the only reason i picked it up
for months
and i've picked up pretty much
exclusively just their first party stuff
right something like this it doesn't
bother me and you know i understand
people were disappointed they expected
a performance upgrade but this is like
people be acting like they've ever cared
nintendo does what nintendo wants
because first
i've always said making their switch be
able to handle more newer games
is idiotic because then they'll have
more competition there's a reason in
their game sell 30-40 million because
that's the only thing you can really buy
on those platforms
that platform so uh you know it's not
necessarily something that they're
they don't want third-party support but
and they don't need it
right and that that's that's their
points like why would we invite more
competition now if you want to jump
through hoops and
go through ex go through people that are
pretty much
exclusively doing ports on the switch
then go by all means go do that but you
know
we're not doing stuff to help you out
like you're gonna have to do stuff on
your end to get your games on
ours not the other way around mm-hmm
okay
this
i never bought this for anything of a
powerhouse
i don't care about the power speculation
i think i've said multiple times on this
show
how how how many times have i hyped up
power on any platform for that but see
it's it's not about the power for me
it's about the frame rate
yeah it's the front well i mean the
power goes into the frame right yeah
but i'm i'm i'm i'm i will not be
purchasing this
i have absolutely zero reason to do so
um why because your back is wider where
would you use
[Laughter]
actually literally charging 50 more for
enhancements that
are really whatever you want to call
them enhancement
old leds led screen
that screen is not a true o led
it's an old
oh i think the old
you're targeting 720p resolution
sub 30 frames like the frames as well
how do you how do you target this
target 720 but are they really going to
hit that mark
there's a lot of 540p going in there and
it's just like it's wild to me because
the series s
is 300 and this is going to be 350.
i'm just like you're kidding like you're
joking right
they put the price at the end
at the end like they were proud of what
they yeah
yeah yeah it's like they came out of a
cave
and stumbled upon an ole i was like oh
this is new no
not like we didn't have an oled uh
portable like a decade ago
i mean they they just they just put an
ethernet cord
report as a fee it was advertised
it you saw how they did it with the
letters flying towards the screen
like it was superman like nintendo
nintendo does
enough crazy stuff when i saw mario
parties gonna have an online feature
i was surprised
let's get a little dead in because
obviously we do a little bit of a
roasting session
i do want to get his opinion of the
switch oled announcement
what are you feeling about it yeah i i'm
mostly pissed because
now i so i mentioned before like i don't
have my switch here
right my mom has my switch and i i want
her to just keep it and so
this would be my fault actually yeah
it'd be a good option for you
this will be like the first switch that
i buy since the
like day one version i don't even don't
even have like addict i don't even have
like the
same version they came out with like the
yeah i got the battery battery life yeah
i don't even have that like the vince on
the top of my switch popped off
i dropped it on wow yeah yeah it popped
off like
yeah like that this was the switch is
like uh it's it's it's doing better hold
it
let me go grab it let me go grab it yeah
i mostly i mostly just aggravated
because i
needed to buy a new one anyway and if
i'm gonna have to buy one for the first
time in
five years four years then i want it to
be the most souped-up
craziest thing so i don't have to buy
another one
a year later because now it's kind of
like all right if they're gonna come out
with a switch like a true switch pro
with a 4k
screen and everything else like
it's like come on i just bought in
one yeah i like the
o.l.d yeah the old
i even had this with e3 too where i felt
very disappointed
in nintendo's e3 showing
it's pretty bad man and that that's why
i'm like like that's
never overheat
[Laughter]
again like you said all day like this is
something that you would be interested
because again your situation
mama butch go she's got the switch gets
moving to the new spot
you need to get a new switch so the
timing is finally good and i get that
for you because you're like okay i'll
also get the most beefed up version of
whatever it is
yeah but provided you didn't have that
situation
provided that you did have your switch
would you still have picked up
the switch oled no
and that's what i was saying like luca's
totally right i am
i i am under nintendo's spell i get
so angry and frustrated when they're
like the expectation
doesn't meet reality but like this is
like i'm like connected for
life to nintendo like i am not it's
they're like family to me that
brand is family time i guess so like i'm
still gonna
get whatever the pro is whenever it does
come out and then
buy 1800 games for it so we're still
under the impression that
that that that's that's in the making
right i think i i think that's just the
next console
yeah i i think all that information got
kind of bunched in together
and nobody knew what's going on give it
to me and it i just think
i think all the dlss stuff and stuff i
think that's that's
that that's real somewhere but that's
not this console
i guess yeah we could get five more
years of switch iterations
and we won't get any of that stuff like
when it comes to the switch
uh the nintendo like i have such a low
expectation
[Music]
like i remember when the last mario
party was announced i was so hyped
because i grew up on that game
and then when i found it was only co-op
couch co-op
online i was like
what kills me is the price point they
because they they give you
they get they they put these features in
that trailer like it was the greatest
thing
ever yeah and then they have the
audacity to charge you 350 for it
and the worst part is it's gonna sell
and it's gonna that's the thing we know
it's good
listen i'm stuck having to get it i tell
you oh wait you can't get it
no remember the story i told you about
my my nephews right my wife and my niece
that um so i told them
yeah but that's the thing i had
purchased them stand still two years ago
my sister made me bring them back
because she was like
i don't want each of them to have one
and i don't want you purchasing it for
them so the only way they're going to
get it from
get this system from you is if you give
them your hand-me-down that i'll accept
you're not going to go out and buy it
right okay so as soon as the
oled got announced yes my sister calls
me like your nephew wants to talk to you
did you see the new switch so what are
you giving me
oh so they okay so they can
attic why are you getting this like
obviously not you guys why are you
getting this you can get a stand still
you can get the one they have now
and i'm just like why would i do that i
agree i agree
agreed for a new a person who's either
new to the ecosystem
or uh has to get a secondary switch for
whatever reason right i just a new
switch on another
this is this is let me jump in this is
i can't believe i i got caught again
yeah
i i can't believe i can't believe
i was bamboozled again
at this time i can't blame myself too
much only because
switch inside a community you know what
i'm saying is
the switch inside the community was
celebrating acted like they were right
it was like
i mean you know bloomberg and what's the
man's name
the japanese guy that i trust and you
know i ain't trying to throw nobody in
the bus but these are people i trust and
i'm like
dlss you know what i'm saying
go ahead okay look at it let me get my
bars off nintendo
has a lot of um iterations from your
systems
yeah so there's a good i mean it's
possible the switch pro could be coming
right
it's a couple of years especially since
there's like the chips
shortages right right right now so that
might be playing a factor as well
and they're just like we're going to put
this o-l-e-d oh
o-l-d yeah
in the meantime yeah i mean they could
still be right like you know you're
true these are reputable sources like
yeah i mean i don't want to i don't want
to be like
yeah i think all that information did
get conflated and all of that stuff is
true in some
regard it's just nobody knew exactly
unless these people are just making up
this stuff right unless they're just
my kid got the fraud alert i just want
to know how many times i gotta get
punched in the face
hey you know what's funny like like we
literally just went through man we
should stop like believing in this stuff
and then like literally 15 seconds later
i mean maybe it still exists
yeah yeah you know what's funny though
what makes me what makes me laugh
is that people go out and blame nintendo
yeah
that is true that's why that's why
it's all for it's my own fault like i
said the switch
insider community no dls
further stick is not coming in hot no
dlss
no resolution but no bluetooth nintendo
come on
once again like did you guys expect
bluetooth when have they ever done
bluetooth
it is like a standard feature but
they'll have it on the switch three the
switch three will have bluetooth
all right you got that and they got the
nerve to be advertising with graphics or
ethernet
like
timeline i said what new switch yeah
so i click it and i'm like yeah oh no
ethernet has been out in the system
since 2001.
vita
like at the end of the day look i get it
for the new
you know people who are going to be new
switch owners or you need a replacement
no doubt but it's just like this is
i think the issue that you guys have is
like i've how are we going to expect
this type of thinking from a company
that still got like 2
000 to the 2000s online features
you can't even message people oh you
can't that that's my
thing that's why i have such low
expectations with the switch like
when i saw mario party i was literally
like this oh i mean
whatever it's not gonna be online and
when they showed at the online man
you would think i'm back in the 2000s yo
[Laughter]
like it's just i i just remember what
you said
yeah next year that they're gonna
is
[Music]
to me it's like what's that uh saw i've
used the expression all the time which
is snatch
no snatching snatching defeat batching
defeat from the jaws of victory
this was a slam dunk like you just had
to do like two or three things
and it would have been good you know
what i'm saying i mean it would have
been like
the masses would have been more behind
it and the sad thing luca is
people are still gonna buy going to
buy this in drawers so it enables them
to continue
these slight revisions and this behavior
when when they're fan based when the
majority of their fan base just
continues to
give them money and continues to buy
these systems with the bare minimum not
even the bare minimum it has nothing
okay and you know the crazy thing is i
as soon as this was announced i
tweeted it out like wow this should have
been the switch y'all launched with and
it really resonated with people but it's
like
that seems pretty obvious to me you know
yeah the problem luca
is a large portion of their consumers
are kids
that's the ones that you you buy you got
eight kids you're buying all eight of
them a switch like
yeah that is the portion of their
community and guess what they don't care
about
none of this yeah like they just want to
play the game
that's why for the most part nintendo
didn't care about none of this
online stuff because they encourage you
to link up with other switches and play
yeah so like that's why they got away
with it for so long because like
look like super smash brothers we might
want like a stable online connection
but stacy billy and [ __ ] no you're
right
you know what you wanted something
because at the end of the day it's more
beneficial for them
to have multiple switches in one
household
than it is for them to really focus on
online infrastructure will make you play
with other people
online in a proper you you order some
bro i think that that
the portability of it because remember
the online infrastructure even you got
you guys are we
you owners i mean like didn't they have
a somewhat online infrastructure before
like better than what
the three were you the
it's still probably the same
infrastructure from the weekend
yeah yeah it's it's like you know like
you know i get the
you know the domestic relationship thing
yeah what's funny is like
it's like it's like a weird domestic
relationship like people getting upset
when nintendo don't even say nothing
it's like people getting upset other
like other people hyping up your girl
the whole the hope that the relationship
would change
based on sources that's what we was
going to stop drinking
no yeah well not he has never
shown you anything
i mean um makes a good point like the
system is for kids yeah
yeah that's a good point that's also
probably why they have like
if you saw in the footage on the video
they still
show people like with the stand at a
picnic table a roof
and the more i think about it it's like
that has to be
for parents being able to say well my
kids can at least go outside with it
yes it has to be my health problem
what if this switch is okay so we know
that it's a tegra chip take a one chip
that has been modified to hold it back
right all i just said is just release
the tegra one chip to
uh actually be used in its fullest
that's that's it
you don't really have to do much just
release that
you don't even have to go tegra too you
really don't no no tegra 2 because
i watched digital foundry where they
were able to get down to the system to
overclock the
system so it can actually run crisis and
it actually ran better so it's
actually nintendo holding back
just to point out just to point out king
you want nintendo to overclock they own
this no
no no there's no you know what it is
they underclock their
system all i'm just saying is just
release the
just let it be right yeah just does it
take over what i think because what it
is
is the battery life because of the
portability aspect
that's their in my opinion that's their
concern i think that's the biggest
concern i'm going
real quick i'm gonna in this poll uh i
asked
the the the community do they think i'm
gonna change my mindset on skyward sword
and 59 percent of them said no i'll put
a poem related to this stuff all right
no doubt
i want to move on because time is
limited for then and i want to try to
sneak in
this last topic while we have them and
uh this
is usof so uh let's get it man sony's
let's stay to play right yeah so we had
a state of play from sony i think it was
this past
thursday and uh fairly light on stuff
that i'm super excited about
but um the things let me just focus on
the things that i that i really like
obviously
death loop was kind of the star with
nine minutes of gameplay
uh shout out to xbox game studios see
that game looks amazing
shout out to arcade i definitely just
looks absolutely amazing
on the other stuff that really stood out
to me is a game that we've talked about
in the past that
we just the moment we saw that is an us
game and that is cfo
um the the developers of this game
also made a game called absolver that
came out on the ps4 initially
early on in the ps4 generation and i
enjoyed it because it
it really was this thing where there was
a lot of variety in the hand-to-hand
combat
and there was it was just a very sort of
fluid thing that
you know for fans of old school is that
70.
no i'm not i better not be seventy
dollars but
whatever we'll get past that okay but
let me just talk about
why why this game is cool and why
uh i guess the lords would gravitate to
it right
we're big streets of rage fans would be
big double dragon fans
as much as we love those older games
right once you get really good at those
games
the things you can do within the game in
terms of variety of beating up your
opponents
is very limited right you will start
doing crazy and weird stuff like
oh um i'm going to stand over here you
throw the guy my way and i'm going to do
a spin kick
okay like this is the sort of stuff you
would do to try to like
just increase the replay value of the
game what sifu was attempting to do
is taking those sort of basic tenets of
of beat em ups
and applying them to arenas and set
pieces where
everything is interactive and depending
on where you attack your enemy and where
they are in the world
is it it's gonna give you a different
animation
in terms of like how they're being
affected by the world how they're being
hit by a table
a wall a piece of you know a whatever
bottle
and there's really no game that i've
seen
that's attempting to do this where it's
going to play out differently every
single time you play it depending on how
you attack your enemy
um and that's kind of the dream for
somebody who's loved these type of games
forever right
you know you know 905. you know what's
funny though
like i felt so i don't care about this
game but i was watching it
i was watching jay maynary uh stream
that's how i was watching it was through
his reaction
they said 20 21 like you know how like
when
it's crazy is how they did it because
most of the time people do something
like that
when it's being up not pushed back you
know what i'm saying because they want
to see yo
it was coming out november now it's
coming out september you should be hyped
it's like they did the reverse it's like
yo it was coming out in 2020
we'll finish up solving that we gotta
get there
i love that and i really hope that game
uh
is all that i see that the promise is
sort of lived up to
um beyond that moss too moss was one of
the
one of the kind of standout psvr games
um
moss 2. i i kind of wish they'd just
hold on to it for psbr2
i don't really see why right released
the psvr one
um because they just haven't talked
about it and psvr one again
they just it doesn't seem like there's a
whole bunch of new stuff coming i know
we saw stuff
work before but i don't i just don't see
the excitement around it so
i hope they're not putting this game out
to die on psvr because
again they haven't confirmed and this is
another very nintendo maybe playstation
type thing where
they haven't confirmed that psvr one
games will play on psvr too
right the expectation this vacation is
dead but
we know what happened to the
expectations what delivery was real
he said you're dealing with sony yeah
so that was it the other stuff was kind
of smaller games and whatnot that really
didn't stand out to me um
but yeah that was it for enough let's
get up lord there man did you get a
chance to
watch the state of play and if you did
were there any standouts
what did you take from it yeah number
one was moss
ii by far i i loved that first one on
psvr but
really good yeah to your point though
it's like i'm in a new apartment with
just the ps5 i'm not
haul my ps4 and my psvr
one and the move controllers across
state lines
just to play moss 2. like i want to play
that game very very
badly but it feels like that honestly
could have been like one of the
standout titles that they formally
announced psvr to
within a like a launch date and
everything around but
it felt like a missed opportunity or
something um and i'd love for
that game to like really showcase the
power of the psvr
too rather than be made for psvr
one um and then just playable on psvr
too
no it's a good point just to follow up
like what do you
i don't know we're just guessing with
speculate like what do you think
kingslab
i just want to know what what do you
think the mindset behind
you know the ps422 is with them is it
something that you think is just not
ready yet and then it was still way
farther away than
many anticipated that's why maybe this
type of moss announcement is
the amount of like blockage i have for
uh vr games
i didn't even know there was a vr game
oh my god
yeah i think it's probably much further
off than
folks would expect and that's why the
only thing i think we've really seen was
on the playstation blog
right like that's what a strange way to
say anything but
that was a way to like make sure the
hardcore fans
knew that something was coming without
like making some big bombastic
announcement and getting the hype up for
something that's not like coming for a
long time
just to clarify is this the same blog
they announced horizon was coming out
next for this channel
was this i think so yeah i think it was
a playstation vlog yeah
yeah it's an information type of
situation
and we're gonna we're gonna announce
something but not
feel it no but i guess so pretty much
for you lord dan the other the
lamas any other title or that was like
the main one for you
yeah i can't remember the name of it
it's the one from uh super brothers
okay it's like it's like a it's like a
space fairing one
which is kind of procedurally generated
i don't have a listener
i think i know what you're talking about
yeah like it was a procedurally
generated joint
um yeah i'm looking right now it's not
yeah
to your point king i was like not very
hyped up about
any of these things at all but like the
the jet the far shore game i thought
okay that could be cool because
super brothers put out like really cool
games in the past
um but yeah it did feel
on the whole it was like you know
were you not impressed with the with the
the new uh
the new layer of sheen on the throat
baby game
i i liked death stranding but i didn't
like it enough to not play it when
there's like the world is open you know
what i mean
yeah yeah that's like a pandemic game
like i can't walk outside so i'm gonna
walk in a walking simulator yeah
you know yeah one game that i forgot to
mention i thought just was just
impressive animation-wise
it was the demon slayer game in terms of
animation like it really does look like
the uh like
like the movie like that like the anime
it really does sort of move very nicely
yeah no doubt no doubt lady luca so you
muted this one make sure you study i
want to get your
opinion on the uh state of play if you
got a chance to watch it any uh
standouts for you i actually
didn't watch it
you're good you're good you're good
you're good the right decision
so somebody came through and they let us
know exactly what they were going to be
showing and i was like oh thank you i
don't have to watch this wow
so once you saw the list the anything
maybe
the death stranding director's cut or
anything
yeah to me i mean def loop is something
i'm already gonna get
like you know i don't need to see any
more of that game yeah okay but there
was nothing on that list where i was
like oh
no i was like no thank you so i could i
commend them for you know being very
honest about what they were showing so i
didn't have to waste my time
savage respectfully respectfully
lord addict uh what about you man stay
to play
i enjoyed it it was uh i it showed me a
little bit more on why i should get
death loop
i i'm still in this mindset where death
loop's not dishonored so i don't care
but um you know it showed me like okay
this is not dishonored but
you know this could be a good experience
it's just
like i see them doing the blink on there
i'm like that's not dishonored why are
you blinking like that
so like so it kind of like frustrates me
with stuff like that but
you know i can't expect them to make
this honor for the rest of my life
so it is what it is uh what i'm a little
worried about that though because you
look at uh whatever what's it called red
dot what is it uh
whatever the the red dawn or whatever
the one the other one the vampire one
yeah
right it's kind of they they doing their
team
yeah pretty much like pretty much so
it's like
i don't yeah it is their thing i don't
want him to get stagnated
mechanics you're out of control oh no no
let's not do michael baby let's not do
that
that's a joint phrase
it comes to me like i do feel like you
know like lucas said they were very
open and honest with you so if like you
was disappointed that's your fault it's
not fair
i guess this is my fault i got the other
side for you king
go for it like at the end of the day
like regardless if they showed you this
day to play with um
with death loop like we we can all agree
that
this isn't the state of the play that
the people expected
first one after e3 yeah yeah
when i first saw him scrolling through
twitter i saw that
oh we're having to study the play you
know like you see something you're like
oh you know what it is
so you know like you see something you
know what it is and then you start
reading you get disappointed the longer
you
yeah i'm like oh state of play we good
and i'm sitting there i'm like when is
this man i'm like
oh
[Laughter]
i was just i was disappointed because
like i was expecting that
i'm about to see the you know game play
for god of war ragnarok i'm about to see
you know what i said nope yeah i'm about
to see
uh you know the release date for maybe
horizon
um west whatever that is so like i
just like the anticipation on next-gen
games
possibly on the on the playstation and
then when you see it's like you know
we're highlighting
a game that we've highlighted multiple
times i'm like
not fair enough fair enough let's get
king is ready he's dancing he's twirling
there's something he has to say
about this state of place so king the
floor is yours you clearly have a lot to
say
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just double click his name start
laughing don't go over his rant
no he's about to go continue so
same energy people
i remember microsoft coming out being
very clear what they were doing
we have a third party indie show that we
are going to show you
our wares they did that
y'all roasted them y'all went in
was that the gameplay one no no he
talked about the third part
the one that the one that they roasted
microsoft for showing these games
because they wanted bangers i saw no
bangers the only banger was a microsoft
game
need that shout out to phil dominus
maximus here we go
we're tweeting out right
i can't wait for you guys to see what uh
what arcane studio is doing and put that
because we know the best thing you about
to see
is our stuff
so shout out to you for going to a
playstation event
to see microsoft stuff now this is the
best part about the whole thing
it was totally forgettable no disrespect
to any developer
any game that was there i think the
cadence was off
i thought the uh it started off with a
vr game right a vr game that we thought
that they will be announcing
uh the vr2 correct that was a missed
opportunity
so then that fell on deaf ears so just
like dan said
am i supposed to go get my playstation
to take it across
the state live
they're trying to they're trying to kill
that game man yeah
it was i've never got more delight
in watching like everybody having to
manage their money now this is a
difference between when i watch an xbox
event
i don't care what y'all say it's about
state of play
it's about war
this is war this is war this is how you
win the war
when you have uh uh um
the ceos and everybody come out and
they're telling you what we're going to
have
available the key points in the
microsoft show is we have 30 games 27 of
them is going to be in game pass if you
happen to have game pass then
enjoy the show right i have to watch
the state of play with discerning eyes
on where i'm going to put my money
is this because of the lack of game pass
or is this what we're doing well
that's not my issue that's their issue
okay that's a dim right so do you you
have playstation now and none of these
games except for one game i heard was
going to be
uh released in playstation now so that
you
made me say if i wanted to see this game
i can have playstation now so i can
place it plus i mean yeah
to check it out it's a missed
opportunity to have all these wonderful
indie games that were shown that was not
inside playstation now if you want to
prop
up that your your services this is your
services it's in
your store it's on your console it's at
your show
but i have to sit there and figure out
where i'm going to spend my money and
how
this is coming from an individual that
watched disney plus this week
and decided to pay 29.95
for for you know the benefit of the
family right
i saw no benefit for the family in
watching this show
i think that i think the issue with that
is is like microsoft's okay with
spending that type of money to get those
games on their service and
i just don't think sony is that's a sony
problem
no i'm not disagreeing with you it's
just like i think that's mainly where
that's at
like that yeah it's like no problem
spinning mindset it's
taking you for granted microsoft
of second place let's be real right
they're clawing they're fighting their
dead dead
they're jumping at that kid in the back
of the room that's waving his hand
he wants you know he has the answer
right but they're always calling on the
guy in the front
he's doing his best he's studying he's
working hard right he's trying to get
you hungry
he wants your attention the other one is
taking you for granted
so you're putting out a show that you're
going to watch and you're going to say
well i'ma buy two or three of those
games
i'm going to spend my bucks but they're
not going the extra mile to get you
right right so when i watch it i'm
watching it with discerning eyes on what
i have to pay for and what i'm going to
pay for
i'm not paying for anything there and
and the best part about it is the most
important game
that i would have spent money on is a
microsoft game that i know
when that exclusive time is up it's
coming in game pass right and i don't
have to worry so let me ask you that's
what i took
just a dump does it double down so in
your opinion
it the show would have had more value
for the indie stuff
if they would have packaged or say a lot
more of them included into the
playstation plus service would that
have made it more attractive to you if
they would have said
and this would have been a reason for me
to get playstation plus okay or
playstation now or whatever service that
you have on
your on your console right we're going
to show you 13 games
out of these 13 games uh 12 of them
will be inside playstation now
playstation plus
what are you serious
i gotta agree with them like that the
thing is is like i get that people have
the mindset and it's okay to
like look like you know playstation
they're like well playstation's not
microsoft and it's like look i
understand that but it's like at the end
of the day we can't act like microsoft's
not doing
the things they're doing and right and
like we should encourage
some form of competition with yeah no i
get it
i'm referring to the people that say we
don't need these games in playstation
now we need to buy these games all right
they don't want the option to get a
minute service
my thing is like look like just because
you know
things things are things are fine with
playstation
a lot of you know the people you know on
on social media stuff they have that
like that that might that's how it's
always going to be and it's just like no
like right now micro i feel like it's a
little bit
of like a reverse thing that happened
2013. it's like you know they that
microsoft came off of a good 360
generation
that's why call of duty was still with
microsoft at that time right
and you know microsoft had had that time
at the beginning
to really get stuff together so that way
a few years from then
when sony started launching stuff it
would be a little bit more even but
microsoft didn't do none of that
right they they stayed they stayed
coasting down the road
and then when sony got those
quote-unquote bangers up and running
it was just like the road just was like
this
i mean listen you guys are making valid
points i do understand what king is
going
with the value proposition if those
games were announced in the service
because it then it makes it more
attractive but
i just think it's two different
philosophies i think their philosophy is
you know our games or quality or
whatever we can rely
on this you know track record of quality
and they're holding on to that right and
then
yeah i feel like they could do that fine
but it's just like i mean we can't see
here and act like
every game that was shown at that state
of play was was fire oh no absolutely
to your point yeah to your point and
king's point it's like
you know king's looking at those games
is like look you know i don't know if
i'm buying all that but if they would
have had a service like
a game pass you know what i'm saying
then it's like okay now what's king's
worth
you allow me to partake
like he he about you know experiment now
i'll give it a shot i would have
another would give it a shot i guess i
saw it then i'll give you i really do
think like to king point i really do
think that
even if you don't you're still resistant
to the idea of first party bangers dan
date or whatever
right you know indies is different yeah
these are different if you give me a
plate like a playstation indies
initiative that's more of a service
right you i think in a lot of ways you
also you rectify these issues that
indies are having with playstation in
terms of discoverability and
if you create an initiative specifically
for indies where the focus is on them
and these games could be brought to the
forefront
and play crafting yeah there's a way to
discover these games
but it makes 100 sense and that way you
have
you have your your your game pass ish
thing
right that's not you know that it's
smaller
but at the same time you are doing a lot
of great work to bring these indies to
the forefront and i think you do rectify
a lot of these issues that these
individual small developers are having
with playstation i think the thing about
that is is we've seen
that i don't know if that's not i mean i
don't know obviously i'm not like a fly
on the wall over there but i don't think
that's like their mindset anymore i
think their mindset
is we're going to build our internal
studios we're going
we're going to focus on the highest
quality games yeah that's what i think
i agree i think that mindset is
different and you know
we're going to attempt to do you know
the indies and the
and i feel like they still have a huge
you know presence in terms of third part
uh third-party stuff but yeah
as far as like i feel like their mind
says if you're not making us an x amount
of dollar or more
we don't care like right it's kind of
like that that meme
of that dude that's on the sports that
was like we don't care
it just depends on how they feel about
your game like this is not what the
third time we've seen sifu
right right and then the other games
that you know
you see them in a sizzle reel and never
see them again and all of a sudden
they're out and
to find them you have to know what the
game's name is and type it into the psa
tour and maybe yeah colin mentioned that
real quick look before i go
um do you agree with king or as far as
the uh the sony indies
you know could they should they be in a
like should they work with them to put
them more in the service like a
playstation plus a playstation now or
you feel sony's fine with the way
they're doing things currently
right you said luca right yeah luca okay
just making sure
i think that sony is going to do
whatever it is that they feel is best
for themselves
now um what that is exactly we don't
know yet because
they are very much marching to the beat
of their own drum
and uh they're going about things
differently than a lot of people would
expect
and i think on whether or not that's
actually going to work only time can
tell
you know there's been some indie devs
who've spoken out about certain things
that playstation
has done uh subtly of course
and there's others who really support
the platform and are happy with what
they're getting from them so
i don't know if these games are going to
show up in ps now i don't think
sony is concerned about ps now as it
stands
right now i think they're going to
eventually
start working on that particular
infrastructure but as it stands
their focus is on putting their games on
pc right that's what it seems like and
everything else is just kind of in the
background right now my heart
shout out to kings favorite studios the
pc parts
there but they're going to get
themselves let me forget my point balls
i got to get dan out on time
um you know look at the end of the day i
hear what you coming
king i i think that is something the
cool thing about competition
is that if xbox continues to do what
they doing with the x
id and xbox program with some of these
games being afforded in the game pass
obviously we had
studios like until the end here on
ireland's podcast a small development
studio just a husband and a wife team
you know it went through kind of
development hell for a while it went
away i
found them resurfaced and then come to
find out they were able to get this
amazing game pass deal
to get themself and get over the finish
line with the way they deal with
structure to get the money up front
and the visibility on the storefront
that is huge where
you are literally your game is right
next to the gears awards the halos and
all that when you open
that is huge for an indie so that's what
the hope is as far as them and like i
said shout out to
to liam and or you know the outcry from
the development community on that side
and hopefully
sony can change that process as far as
the show look i'm an indie guy so i
didn't actually like some of this [ __ ]
you know i actually did like i thought
tales of mega all was fire like what
would you buy him
i'll probably buy tails sifu i'm buying
day one don't don't come for me you know
i see what you're doing
i'm buying seafood is my most i
anticipated that is channel 5 martial
arts that is
day one it's sad that it's delayed to
2022.
but i love the way hurry up and wait
yeah i gotta wait i feel like i feel
like we're gonna have to start uh
what having people check uh oh no you
could do whatever
yeah you could you could check well
let's let's you know we need to i am
copying
literally that's probably like my most
anticipated game of the year outside of
halo infinite i'm gonna be
1 000 on that you know what we need to
do we need to go back on that last sony
conference
because there was a couple there he's
that's day one
he picked those up i did i did i picked
up that job
martial arts tight corridor and then
the mechanic when you die and then you
age and you become like a man
like that's the ninja that's the gaming
ninja right there
i'm all in day one the tribes of make
all look hot
it was like ten player co-op it was one
game that had me in it
actually yeah
multiple aspects of myself this shout
out to neospark for you
but yeah like i said i like that it was
the north mythology joint 10 player the
co-op i liked the customization
i liked the bosses you were fighting all
the dog looking like creatures yeah
what are you doing we don't know we
[Laughter]
that's you know normally we're used to
games a lot of that on that caliber it'd
be like
20 30 dollars but but i i do feel like
because you know they've done the the
raising prices by
ten dollars if it was gonna be a 30 this
gin is probably going to be a forty
dollar game
not gonna stop you
the fact that you don't know how how
many levels what's up
with that it could be one arena
[Laughter]
49.95
and it come behind two weeks later for a
season pass for 29.99
even now not fair enough fair enough but
just to conclude you know that looked
good
you know like i said trust the big up
provided the price is that 70 i will get
it
um seafood doesn't matter i'm sorry
fonts sifu it does not matter
i am getting that game that game is fire
that speaks to me
i'm getting it so um and definitely look
more impressive but to
solve point in kings point you know i'm
like
fire but i know that's coming together
there there was some sort of speculation
that that game is straight up
exclusive yeah well well now that y'all
said phil
jumped out on front street it said once
phil said that i'm like oh
i could just wait and get that for free
99.
i think they're already reporting that
it's a year exclusively yeah what year
is weird
yeah yeah yeah it is what it is foster
don't say 80.
you might be listening to those titles
they're not going to come in the back
door
and tell you know we want to extend
their expensivity no no no
because you're gonna that's not gonna
happen yeah this is because microsoft
i'm gonna laugh to go walk out the door
it's not the square enix thing they
can't get away but eddie is
i can understand people's disappointment
wanting big the bigger titles i can
totally understand if they give a low
score
respect you know for me i do like the
indie so i thought there was some joints
that was good and um yeah that's pretty
pretty much what i got weren't a fan of
fists no i'm good i thought
it's like i said i thought it was it was
a decent show like i thought it was
entertaining for the most i want the
same energy
but it is the same like it's like i said
like this isn't the one that we expected
though
yeah right okay
and i get that and that's what i said i
brought that up kingwood
act like i didn't bring that up see
listen
see everybody you're talking to me king
but
[Music]
what's the point they're missing the
point the reason why sony wasn't at e3
the reason why they were not there the
reason why they were not
competing the reason why they didn't
have a show because they don't have
games
like uh time to end the show
an absolute pleasure the legendary
dan butchko of play crafty player nyc
coming soon
where can i find people find you give
them as much information about this
amazing
program you got going on for sure for
sure so you can follow all things play
crafting at justplaycrafting.com
if you want to head over to play nyc
whether it's in person
or tune into the stream throughout the
weekend it's play
dashnyc.com so play
nyc.com and yeah follow me on twitter
it's at dan butchko d-a-n-b-u-t
c-h-k-o uh and at play crafting so we
have a lot of stuff coming up this
summer
and play nyc is really gonna be an
awesome special time so if you can make
it in person
we'd love to see you there if not make
sure you tune in online for the stream
for the two days nice absolutely keep
your mind nice meeting you
nice to meet you too keep in mind for
people that's never been to an event
this is a really
good event that you know it's not going
to be extremely crowded because they're
still
building up their brand and you can you
can have a good time play some games
it'll be a good
you know first entry for a lot of people
that's never been to event because
i ain't going life i've never been to
event going to like an e3 or something
i'd be intimidated there's
thousands of people walking everywhere
like y'all dan driver yo shout out to
hip hop gamer the chat the lowest let's
go my man dave which goes audience
fire love gamer yes hip hop is in the
building you're getting a lot of love
the
the fans again the realm really loved
the knowledge the gems you were dropping
on in
on the indie game scene the development
side i love what you're doing the
promotion of it i love that new york
talk keeping us in the conversation
bringing these conventions and making it
eventually one of the meccas of gaming
so that it's synonymous we ain't got to
go to the west coast all the time that's
right we could
brought her away thanks that rockstar to
the to announce gta 6
let's make it happen we're working our
way there we'll get there
go get skyward sword and you have to
play it the way it was intended to be
played
split up those joy cons no pro
controllers let's go
let's go solve yourself and solve your
salutation for you yeah absolutely
i can't i can't wait for august um i i
love playing yc
that that first event was just amazing i
love the intimacy of it i love the fact
that it's just
it's just so much new york love like cox
says that we don't get that on this side
um and just i i'm excited to be a part
of
seeing it continue to grow so now august
brothers i don't know what we're going
to do with cog we're going to have to
like get some like
coming here
look good enjoy your day brother i will
see you august
7th right august 7th august 7th and 8th
yeah we got four weeks we will
definitely be there on the 7th
and it will be fun to cover the event
and see you in your element once again
enjoy your sunday brother have a good
one we got super chats and more messages
we'll try to
[Laughter]
y'all could be messy because yeah i
clearly want to be messy so what's up
i just i just want to ask so this was
the first event that we've gotten from
playstation right since
yes oh here we go let's get it yes oh
okay okay now i can understand that then
like
um
where you're coming from king
playstation insiders don't exist
obviously
because i was hearing a lot i was
hearing a lot of things
that were supposed to be at this uh
state of play and it ended up being
indeed
i know
i know that this isn't probably the case
but it's just like man we
we we down here in the middle of july
like like
like i'm low-key starting to feel like
they might not be a chauffeur
the rumor is they're supposed to be
vloggers there's always rumors
the rumor is the rumor the rumor is
the rumor let's go with the facts faxes
y'all showed up
lacking son like like
you showed up to a shootout with a
butter knife
how you gonna show up with your biggest
gun is
how you gonna have the biggest the
showcase is going to be wrapped around
def loop you're in a microsoft game huh
you messy you don't think there's no
there's no chance they can do another
one with horizon the god of war
oh man nobody cares about the horizon
just to click just
just to clarify though it does you know
people can be on your ass
oh yeah i don't care what they come for
they
sickle for anything it still ain't gonna
be better than a microsoft show
i don't care what you can show god of
war all you want you ain't gonna get it
now
you're gonna be like yeah god of war is
coming
i don't know but so you're in flag that
there's still
nothing to show that that have no game
they don't have no they're the only game
they got
so are definitely implied that the real
they got no games narrative should apply
to sony is this what we're doing
yo i mean look we live but it could be
true like
microsoft has so many games they did
multiple shows during the week
you knew when they did they show you
know how confident they was
when they came out they told you we got
30 games
the people who have no games or sony
this year that is it's king right
please vote it's a live phone we're
doing new stuff we don't have no game
what do you need to see
you could say horizon coming out you
don't even know what's coming out this
year
you don't know but we know what's coming
that big bad halo coming oh yeah
it falls right out they remove the
batteries
right no po needed
shout out to the movies for a minute if
they
keep on postponing stuff you keep on
listening to
these insiders the insider has said that
um we will say we
they said i'm gonna get a switch pro
they said all these gays is dropping
from sony this year
i should be listening to them right no
no no no no
insiders be right i don't know when it
was it's not this year
it wasn't last year it wasn't the year
before that so i don't know what's going
on
like whenever i hear these rumors i'm
just kind of like oh okay
i made a lot of people mad because i was
like dylan out here doing more inside
he predicted the playstation inside
what's funny is
shout out to bg be a mess he's the user
he was like
when that ghost thing came up he's like
where was these playstation insiders
when this was announced like
look dick i i'm just surprised you're
going hard you're going real hard at him
you're surprised no i am i didn't expect
this from the indie showcase you know
what i told these dudes i told these
dudes
what's going to happen to sony and y'all
like nah nah y'all are sitting in a room
full of fire
talking about it's okay you need to be
good god of war
[Laughter]
don't tell me that it's not cross gin
because it is
you know i was talking to king about
this and like i'm kind of like
i wasn't there with him a couple months
ago when he was talking about this but
now that we see the ghosts but they're
doing their uh you know
they're just oh the director's
i'm saying that now that we see with the
uh
last of us where they did the the one
where uh
it was with her after the original last
of us game
we seen with uh horizon dawn with the
ice one whatever that is
and now we're seeing a mile spider-man
that you saw uh
that was in a a standalone expansion
after the aboriginal spider-man
and now we're seeing it with ghost where
this another one is after and it's in
standalone
i don't know if that one's a standalone
game but you know i'm i'm starting to
think he
he he might be honest oh we turn it
around
that ragnarok might be like a like a
stand-alone expansion it's not a
full-blown sequel like
oh so all right so are we implying
that oh god here he go so are we
implying that
the lack of games is going to go into
this either director's cut mold
and and dlc like a miles morales kind of
where like
and it might you know i hope i'm wrong i
really do because i really do want an
a good experience of a guard and it will
still be a good experience i enjoyed
miles but right
you know people want spider-man 2 more
than wanted miles
so you know i hope that that's not the
case but i mean
we can't say that that's not the pattern
like right
saw spider-man the next spider-man entry
was like a stand-alone experience it was
it like a
next true but we did get return and we
did get ratchet this year they got this
broke turtle
don't act like that that game didn't
come in really hot
the game is so hot those games like your
system i'll give you
i'll give you ratchet
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
come on now i told y'all ratchet was a
glorified
pull button and what it turned out to be
it was a glorified pull aboard close
button
when the game comes out or on pc because
it is shout out to nexus
yeah shout out to nixon's the pizza
report
i can't wait for y'all to get that
ratchet over please expeditiously
because y'all think this ssd is
something and it's not
y'all think oh it can't be done or the
police station full it will be
so y'all believe in generations you
don't
do you think that if that is the case
that's gonna be a huge issue
like it's a huge issue for the people
that believe i mean if if the game is
good
and the game's good people aren't gonna
care if it's like a sequel or not
but i i do think you know people
expected that
true spider-man sequel in people who
expected
everybody is still selling we talking
all this talk
all these games are selling hot
ragnarok is going to be a sequel yeah i
think i think it's going to be a sequel
now the thing is
if it comes out next year we're talking
about four years removed from from the
launch of the original one right
but four years built on the same engine
can you make a game
that is is as big as scope as the first
one i think you can if it's the same
engine obviously
it's it's it's it's uh crosstalk so
that's a possibility 3.5 hours
the thing that i will say they're going
to give you asgard there you go
the thing that i will say though is like
this isn't like
standard development time would they
have probably a year and a half right
and then you have code
right there yeah yeah sure so like this
isn't standard thing
and i thought but do you i've always
felt like changed the game
as a result of course just take longer
i'm saying that you know it's not a
hundred percent but there is a
possibility this is
this is like kind of a miles morales
standpoint or the new ghost thing like
and i'm not saying that that's a hundred
percent right because that that's clear
that's
i am say i am saying that if you look at
it from the standpoint they said the
game was coming out this year
we regardless if we all was like they're
full full of it
they still said it was coming out this
year true so whether or not
can i can i speak with you i'm in the
background i'm just chiming it's just
providing comments yeah he's providing
context for commentary
regardless regardless
how they perceived it they still
announced it so you know maybe that was
something they just threw at the end of
a state of play for more of a hype
scenario
or maybe the game was actually supposed
to come out this year
right and then if the game was supposed
to come out this year
what that's like what when did 2018
that that's a little bit of time but
like with the covet thing happening
like i personally feel like if it's a
sequel games like coming out to 2023 i
don't think it is
because i feel like i personally feel
like that and it's like i said i haven't
been thinking about this forever i've
always thought that
ragnarok was a next-gen not next-gen but
an actual true sequel but after seeing
the ghost of shashima thing and they
go that's not even that old like you
know what i'm saying like they rebranded
the game
but the ghost thing isn't at all
standalone right it's part of it
it's not as stand-alone they're forcing
you about it they they're they're
low-key making your standalone they're
like the only way you i mean i guess
that's not true because you could buy it
on
you could buy it on a playstation 4. i
mean
you know what king's fault
i'm pulling it back but but i will say
that
you know i don't think the game's coming
out next year i don't i don't think i
i think because uh because the cove it
was originally supposed to come out next
year
uh b but because of covid because
i personally feel like they threw up and
that's that's another thing
no one absolutely no one called them out
that they literally went out there and
lied about a release date
to generate height oh no about the god
of war further they first said
like they said right around everybody
did really yeah just like
that's like they said we believe in
generations to be to generate height
you know that ragnarok put out a release
date yeah they said
they said when they first announced it
yeah they said 22. they said 2021 they
did and
they had the jpeg yeah they wanted
people to go out and buy
playstation 5s and they wanted to gouge
the public and they're like yeah
and i just said after that it's coming
to the playstation 4.
i just i just personally felt like if
that was microsoft
a lot more people like let's say
microsoft did that with
uh let's give an example hellblade
hellblade coming out 2021
they never gave a release date the uh
you know that happened and that was just
delayed out of it and we knew
i think a lot of people were like the
moment that game got delayed out of 2021
hey addict i i think there's something
wrong with the with ninja theory over
there like why are they delaying the
game like
i mean but i felt like when it came to
sony doing it
they're like oh oh it's you know we
didn't expect it to be we've talked
about the double yeah we talked about
that
like the double standard it really does
exactly sony
xbox has to be exemplary all the time i
think that we need to really start
bringing up this that
and i know you know people might
disagree with this we need to stop
this mentality sony makes great games
they can do whatever they want oh
i know you're going because you've had
this i've seen that so many times sony
does whatever
they do they make good games games are
fine
we can absolve them from everything else
in deceptive practices
i mean you have all this energy for sony
but none for nintendo
no no it's because we accept the fraud
let's get to it explain to me where the
energy is different let's get to it
let's go because you're all
like well you know we don't actually
expect much from nintendo i mean i
thought the thing is though hold on i
bought the switch in order to play some
good games you know
i don't expect any power or anything
like that you know it's all good man you
know
over here saying it's okay for
playstation to release these games
and to lie to us okay so let
let me let me ask you here we go so
first off
i've always stated that i've bought
these for this and that for that i
bought the switch for its first party
title about the playstation for its
first birdie title
for the most part is switch going out
there lying to their consumers or is it
the
actual fan base hyping up oh yeah yeah
switching sides
i have stated from the beginning i did
not believe the 4k
yeah he did it so
and i've stated multiple times even in
this podcast i have zero expectation for
sony
i mean for nintendo yeah but when it
comes to playstation
they make great games that's one thing
but it's just like we can't just
like ignore the fact that they're lying
to people they're false advertising
stuff and every time something's brought
up
yo they make bangers though
they're definitely lying well i don't
think the god of war ragnarok teaser i
don't think
that was intended to be a lie i think
the vid situation happened
and they had to push it back and now
that i know that they actually put out a
release date i mean
maybe i'll have a point about it not
being a full
uh sequel it's like yeah you know
i guess ryan is a liar you know what it
is
the thing is like when they when they
said when they when they announced
ragnarok that was leading up to the
launch of ps5 so
we were in the middle of the pandemic
and they they they knew that game wasn't
coming out
let's be real here that like people can
say what they want
that god of war thing is one of the key
reasons that that entire
showcase was even good like it had good
announcements with that god of war
things that people were like
yo i'm good now let's go it was it was
it was it was selected
but it was just a logo too like again
it's
it's hype it was a jpeg and it's hype
and it is just that thing where it's
like okay
we give them that one more thing they
did it with metro prime four right all
that stuff like
even nintendo's done it nintendo we
gotta figure out we gotta give it a
nintendo date
we're still waiting on that metro
nintendo does they put it up but they
don't give a date and they just
walk out the room sure true you're right
you're right
put it up they said and it's out in 2021
and and and to luca's point right why
does why does nintendo not get the same
smoke
is because of that direct competition
between playstation and xbox right
nintendo's like it's very difficult to
say they really are
in their own lane and no matter what
they do like if you don't want to engage
with them
you don't have to and they 100 don't
affect what playstation does or xbox
does right and vice versa
it's like that i feel like that let me
just interrupt you real quick
i feel like that that's the key thing
you know people expect
a certain thing when it comes to quality
in terms of playstation games so they
get that height that generated height
uh people expect certain things from
xbox that you know in a lot of cases
they
they haven't delivered in a while in
terms of their quality but their games
so people give them that
uh that that uh that heat but when it
comes to nintendo
no one really expects anything from
nintendo like we can just be real like
like we're happy if we get an online
feature
which is really sad and it is sad but
it's like at the end of the day it's
like
i've always said like you know voice
your opinion but yeah they got you
they got you no look it happened after
the gamecube
now i'll hear everybody and i remember
the last time nintendo competed the last
time they included
the reason why everybody can go back to
the gamecube and say the gamecube was a
real
shining moment because they stepped up
to the plate with a third party they
stepped up to the plate with their first
party they stepped with
power right where they stepped up to
that power pc remember that
yeah that was that was a game changer
they
really went all out with that console
and the fact that that console did not
beat the playstation 2
or the 360 uh or actually
they went away from that yeah they were
going up against they said you know
that's when the wii came out right
that's when they
they went away from power and they went
towards the gimmicky side of things
and trying to get back to the nature of
who they are
at that moment they lowered our
expectations for
whatever they were going to produce
forward so they tried the gimmicky stuff
on the gamecube with the the little
discs and stuff yeah
they've always been about that that was
just to combat
uh bootlegging yeah good point yeah
on stopping piracy they have like been
yeah they don't like
he started gaming in this era in that
time
and he's seen that how they went down to
the lower
expectations of the hardware itself
right how to give you a switch
see where you i'm used to nintendo with
power with the super nes
mode 7 yeah like they they're out of
that like
they've shown enough evidence that they
don't care right they won that one war
and they like you know what um
that's it i can't financially feel like
the reason that's cost effective for
three to battle
right people with the an addict alluded
to it that demographic
is not us yes the kids don't care about
that
facts though you're right you're right
and and to their point they win it i
just want to backtrack to one thing that
attic said that i do
want to talk about which is you know
because
a company or platform makes quality
gains which we love
right we we want our company to do that
i do agree with attic that that does not
absolve
bad and treacherous business practices
or deception
that's the thing i don't like i don't
like well the games are fired so what
they lie to me about that
but the game's a fire you know so what
they said this about generation but the
game's a fire
so what they're gonna maybe charge me
for a feature that most other people
unlock or whatever the game's a fire so
what we're gonna you know
we're gonna promise hundreds of shows
but the games are fired right
sony's that's the thing i just said we
have to be careful of as gamers i
understand it is about
the games but at the end of the day it's
okay to say look
i love ghost to sashimi i love these
games i'm gonna pick it up and support
but i would necessarily agree with this
practice i don't necessarily agree
with you saying that these games you
know we believe in generations and then
we come to find out later through a blog
post right
that's always coming to the ps4 too and
this you so i'm saying that's the only
thing
it's just i just want more
accountability you can love sony it's
all good like
you know i'm saying just accountability
like yo that's that's not it that right
there ain't it fam you know what i'm
saying
you could go back but that part in it
that's all you could go back you can
look at us attacking
microsoft for them raising the the
the xbox uh
you know we obviously nintendo you know
i i've never been the kind of person
i've always been the first party person
with them
i don't really care what nintendo does
and for the most part even play a lot of
their games but
a couple other games i do enjoy like the
zelda games and
and it's like i said last week with the
ghost of sashimi i think that's
completely bogus
right but if you love ghost fushima you
don't have to eat that
right and the other one other point that
i see another thing is i'm tired of what
about ism
right if if they your platform does
something
that is bad yo but they but they did
this yeah they're pointing their fingers
somebody just said your fam you right
that ain't it
you know what i'm saying what about it
yeah i'm tired what about you you notice
when you tell somebody about their
favorite platform
there's a lot of book passes yeah it's
like the first thing they want to talk
about is y'all but they did
all right just let's address this first
is this right or is this wrong yeah
answer the question
that's a really good point there you
know what i'm saying it's always throw
it again look again talk your talk
listen my thing is
and i'm going to bring it back to
nintendo once again because we are
existing in this space that we're in in
which the console war consists
primarily of playstation versus xbox
right everyone gives nintendo a pass and
it's like well i mean you know it's
nintendo nintendo's just gonna do
whatever they are still waiting for and
then no one ever says anything like
actually this what they're doing isn't
right
just because you don't actually care
about what nintendo is doing doesn't
mean it's
yeah okay like for me personally i'm
like you know i will be the first person
to rag on anything nintendo's doing i
love them
i do the same thing with xbox and
playstation just because i personally am
like
not highly invested in the switch
ecosystem and i have a switch
don't get me wrong but doesn't mean i'm
just going to give nintendo a pass for
whatever it is they're doing because
they're not microsoft and they're not
playstation
it doesn't work like that for me you
know and i really just think
that the reason people in our community
give them a pass
is because they're not xbox and they're
not placed right so they just can do
whatever they
want and everyone's like what's nintendo
and nintendo can do whatever
and nintendo their games are great but
you know who's the game of the fire
yeah the standard doesn't apply exactly
nintendo and i'm just like
i don't care that it's nintendo and
they're not on the same level as
playstation and xbox when it comes to
this console war in your mind
or in their minds what they're doing is
still wrong they are still a shady
corporation
that that's all we say let's just call
it yeah nintendo
honestly nintendo is the worst of the
three they are the worst
they are fun
they don't they don't even pretend to to
act like they listen to you
like at least playstation kind of make i
mean jim ryan comes out there right show
his face like
they you know nintendo will give you a
direct that you cannot respond to
there no there are no qas after the
directs right there's none of this
so they now they they are the absolute a
hundred percent
worst um and the thing about it is the
funny thing is that the playstation
and the nintendo they they're the
leading platforms
they're the worst about it it's like
what is it about it
it is very much enabling and i i just
think for nintendo
when it comes to the power narrative i
understand your guys is beef with like
the
quality of life stuff the internet stuff
that's all that matters i'm never gonna
get off the
now when it comes to the power narrative
stuff i just really do think like
and we've seen it in the past yeah i
don't think the market can support
three systems that kind of do the same
thing no no i get it
we understand yeah i know where you're
at all i want is 60 frames
funny i include that in quality of life
i include that in quality of life
like 60 fps at this point i don't even
care about that no more
i gave up on that
when luca jump online i want to say hi
luca
lucas a message that's all i want to do
my journeys are glorified
let me get that 15 digit number
glorified
oh yo king jumped online today and
that's it that's a cat message
kid party chat can't i just see oh you
was all eight hours ago i knew what you
did last night
that's all it is it's a tracking device
vaccinated that i shouldn't get two cups
of string that i got to do this with my
phone and all this could anyway it is
what it is and it is what it is and the
funny thing is like we always talk about
what
consumers you're going to buy the next
product yeah
we always say hey speak with your wallet
don't do it yeah
we going crazy but let's get to super
chat's fantastic show
and uh before we get to super chats um
lady luca
the legend of scum cast the amazing one
good to have you back in the round sis
it's been a minute
thanks for having me who's good thank
you for doing amazing things over here
um
wow like just get it in get out and we
have
stuff to do like this i don't like y'all
even though i don't like that i'm gonna
break this up
like hey how's it going brother he's all
like luca come join the iron wars
podcast uh clan i'm like oh
oh we're gonna play together right right
crickets i haven't seen cog on since i
joined the clan
and i told her i said yo i said if you
need anything
at any point you see me on is it go
no problem and then and then she was
there with tabs was like yo let's get
this ring going
got my team let's go let's get it going
and we you know it was more people that
was inside our chat that was gonna
jump in if anything went wrong is that
is any spaces no we good bro
don't you want to i will be back let me
settle here your boy had his duke hat on
for a little bit oh but
you always say a game of skills
i'm tired of doing like two jobs so
everyone can do a job
we got big tasks we did too you know
that's the whole thing like the whole
thing is everybody was proficient at
whatever job that they were given
because it was a lot of people's first
time in that raid like myself
at that point in time um she was doing
it the first time and
we got called inside to go into casino
oh no man i remember i got so annoyed
one time that we were doing a rainbow
song i can't remember who it was
and they kept dying opening the portal
and i was like i will call out the
oracles and i will open the political
heights somewhere
when they explaining it to us
i'm an idiot so they explain so you're
gonna go through it you're gonna see
this you gotta do that that was like
after you heard that look and she's like
yeah i said sound good in theory
that's that way they give bad
information like yo whatever you give me
so much information i'm like okay it's
like yeah i have no idea what you're
saying but all right let's go ahead
me and king in here by ours oh okay
well i guess we're just gonna try then i
don't know how this is gonna go
so but it ended up working i mean we
ended up
so yeah i mean you know great experience
with the boys uh missing cog
i don't know where he's been i'm gonna
get i got you sis i got it i'm coming
back
all right all right but yeah you guys
can find me on twitter at the ashley i
have a youtube channel
called the ash and lucca and we do a
podcast called scumcast in which we
discuss
uh gaming in the first half we do other
stuff in the second half like
tv shows movies life stuff whatever's
going on
what time what time is that show says
wait what channel can we find it on
yes what time is it right now okay first
of all
it's been on a consistent time for a
year sir thank you so much
eight o'clock right now right now right
now it is uh 7 p.m central time 8 p.m
eastern
i just i just i changed it now you know
the excuse i gave out for changing it i
was like you know my panel's full of men
who are married with kids or that
no the truth is uh i was getting my hair
done and i kept recognizing the show
she looked at the priorities of the
building laughing
it was good yeah i was like i'll go
ahead and just change the time it's fine
so it's 7 p.m
central 8 p.m eastern my channel which
is
the ash and lucas no doubt salute that
paddle the panel kind of fun yeah the
piano is amazing with slo-mo
meta when he shows up every six months
all day i haven't seen all day
well technically speaking nautical's
always been a member but like since i
had it at
uh early time he couldn't come through
because he's at work but now he shows up
because he can so he's you know gaming
fortes on their amazing guy
so you know uh shout out to those guys
they're all so much fun and
i think the show is very funny i got my
boy death right there
yeah deaf singer recently
[Music]
he is the english person that's in our
reaction yeah we always get deaf
it's amazing to have around luke also we
got to get your super live reactions if
you have time
if you're not doing it for yourself for
skill cast as well but it's good to have
you back in the realm
the ashen one lady luca thank you so
much
absolute pleasure let's get these uh
super chats and dennis rolls off
go if you're in their hustle put her
info yeah put her info in the chat you
know what i'm saying and look you ain't
got to stay we got mad reading to do
we're
going to stay around for this video i
want to but um yeah good uh solve you
got everything caught up with the show
honestly you know i was just throwing
them back down so give me a moment yeah
no doubt no doubt no doubt
i'll go ahead and announce some stuff
real quick okay so so i i see you guys
enjoyed the
the sea thieves thing a lot
uh i wasn't referring to you but okay
i'm saying they loved it oh i thought
you said i loved it
so you know i'm gonna go ahead and you
know point out i pointed on the stream
but obviously you know
there's more people watching the actual
podcast than they are or that
uh how we're gonna do that because that
takes a lot out of us we all have to
come together find a good time
uh so what we're gonna put those live
react those live commentary community
things
with just all four lords we're gonna put
those like you know
on a go tier uh so right now you know
the people that subscribe to our patreon
the people that are members of our
youtube channel
you know appreciate all of you guys
appreciate everyone for coming uh but
how we're gonna do it is every time we
get
15 new between both of those platforms
we'll
do another community stream now there's
been arguing among the lords of what
game we're going to play
so so i figured the good way of doing it
is once we hit that goal of 15
let's say uh we will we will all come
together with a game
all four of us because ironically four
po four people
and we'll let oh look at what's going on
bryant tony bryant said
he really wants to play chivalry live
tony bryant i do too and that that
that's why i'm going the direction i'm
and then we'll put it on you know uh
we'll let
everyone pick the game fair enough fair
enough no doubt no doubt
um don't you go solve a week caught up
or you're right yeah ready to go yeah
no doubt no doubt oh no one said i just
got here and i already know the king is
right
shot oh big way pause the shot what up
dude what was going on that's right
oh my god so let's get these super chats
uh we got raiden blade 10 pound super
chat
thank you very much uh i forgot what it
was that we said we
congratulated him on so i forgot
congratulations
there we are percolator nine thousand
five dollars
hello lords i'm just here to pay my dues
hope you'll be worthy someday have a
great day panel you know that you do as
well who goes to the club
and we got italian clowns fifteen
dollars of attack oh what up
clown dear king is the switch oled
the equivalent of the tcl tv
i feel bad for all those who just paid
scalpers for their switches all hail the
king
that's the overhead switch
the old
i see the stream they're constantly
pushing for 300 likes
he got close stream one
it's like doing the whole game it's not
happening he's going to finish it in one
sitting ladies
multiple streams because you got to
finish it right i
i will i will start and i'll play
minesweepers
on my mind no no what else you guys saw
uh then we got spready spent five
dollars in the chat nintendo
with the new screen now you can really
see your games running like crap
switch pro get got held back because of
chip shortages okay
possible no it didn't yeah i think we
got exactly what they intended to get
but the wide back made it out the door
right yeah
what paul king just want to pull king is
right 91 percent 91 percent well he
dominated with this kingdom
is king right about what oh what
playstation got no game oh yeah
there we
difference is nintendo sells out of
profit microsoft has taken loss on the
series
s and x okay
smitty smith five dollar super chat the
switch is coming in hot and straight
into the bushes the biggest
profit because they're selling you old
tech microsoft was telling you
playstation
[Laughter]
pathetic nintendo fans have no
self-control i agree
being one of them i agree 100
there we have don otaku once again
nintendo is going into the ds3ds order
light
to xl to dsi to new 3ds upgraded specs
yeah it makes sense makes sense then we
look uh we have gerald mack two dollar
super chat death loop looks like a
dishonored reskinned in my opinion
yeah it's the same mechanics like i said
the mechanics are very similar so it's
just a matter of what's different about
this game
um you die then we got yeah
it's it's my easy it's easy it's about
the five dollars in the chat let's say
it the play the play of state
was a reactionary move about all the
sony don't support
indy's narrative why they only showed
indie games king tub
they don't have any games you wanted
something
there looking
nintendo finesse is real i'm buying the
switch quarter
quarter step day one along with 20
of their base if the pro comes next year
i'm in for that too
yes sir only time would tell and as
always
hey king boo boo boo hey forte
savages oh hold on two shot i've got to
interrupt because i i'm not trying to
make it uh
be better about the merch of getting
their shout outs because we always tell
them to we're gonna shout them out so uh
shout out to first toto dope he brought
that snapback he said take the knees
king
with that snapback and then just now
anonymous didn't say they they just
bought a classic t the iop
drip the letters you know what i mean
keep in mind uh anonymous keep in mind
right now
uh king is in the early stages of giving
you guys a new merch so yeah
we're working on that and we're working
on that um but you got a little man
little manny's
in progress we're working continue so
and we have uh donald taco two dollar
super chat damn no love for fists
it was a stand out for me yeah it seemed
like a cool metroidvania side scrolling
uh with a
yeah with a handheld combat 70 bucks
[Laughter]
let's see if you're going to put your
fist in your pocket
just just question real quick have you
did the poll yet
no okay just making sure that we got a
phillip carlisle two dollars with a chat
i'm a playstation guy and stay the place
sucked
hold on shout out i got a shout out
midway that was
midway that brought the t-shirt to drift
make sure you put a message when you buy
the [ __ ] there's a spot to put a message
so we can shout you out you'll be funny
midway's like ah
someone didn't put a name i'm about to
claim that
you got to take credit for my boy wait
wait i know he for real
he's stealing
[Laughter]
all right clutch man five dollar super
chat i got my kyoto fushimi theme
controller early those who know
know shout out to xbox design live no
doubt
then we got raiden blade five pound
super chat god of war 2023-24
horizon forbidden west 2022-23 late
wow okay inside a raid and blade
all right brayden blade once again five
pounds super chap
they should have known they should have
shown god of war alpha god of war 2
alpha footage even if it's not ready
fifa 3i did it but to leave your fan
base hanging stockholm syndrome
in coming again yeah
i don't know that would have played too
well if they showed some bad footage
um bret bingham two dollars super chat
sony state of state of pay
wow that's what that is this is a state
of pay
that's what's up then we have
soma king with the two pound and 93 cent
super chat thank you so much i
appreciate it donating my free google
rewards credit salute
so we got some google rules then we got
smitty smith five dollars in the chat
you saw the insiders need to go outside
for a change the book of acts
how is sony highlighting a game coming
out in september with death loop and the
next big game that's supposed to come
out is kinah
which is august and a no show um
they know what i know
stop sound okay well listen it looked
like everything else it looked like the
same thing
it looked like the same thing let's see
if we got a good story let's see if the
frame rate hold up
but isn't that supposed to be coming to
microsoft though yeah
actually right i don't know yeah senior
past
dad yes time
lords cheers thank you my brother no
doubt we got italians
clowns once again five dollars nintendo
needs to reach out to tcl for a better
screen
they got the best man they got the best
baby
[Laughter]
then we got ready to blade to power
super chat stockholm syndrome equals ps
gamers abusive core
switch has more 60fps first party games
than the ps4 though
[Laughter]
then we got hargie shanae five dollar
super chat another great show salute to
the lords and
king is always right thank you brother
atlantic
that's good we're caught up all caught
up no doubt it is time for that
pole attic you want to do something what
you gonna do so what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna put the poll
in there when he says the poll right you
guys just vote
before you guys leave and we get
curiosity just curious
a live interaction on what's going on so
new
logged in iop weekly poll brought to you
it's actually courtesy of
i'm gonna butcher your name brother
select bang double oh seven
bang select bank double 007 courtesy of
our select patreon tear so we're gonna
be trying to include y'all more the
patrons more who are actually in there
supporting us
and they want to do polls you guys can
put your old polls in as well
we'll do some slight edits if there's
anything too crazy but
um in regards to the release of
battlefield 2042 by ea and the potential
of game pass
which answer closely mirrors your
thought process on purchase
the choices are eight seventy dollars no
campaign
and multiplayer only makes it a wait for
game pass
option b battlefield 2042 looks amazing
day one by i'm not waiting for anything
when it releases or c i don't care we
all know when
big card come through it's all over for
battlefield
those are the choices they are up right
now in the chat live
or like i said it's also at the same
time on lords of gaming.net as well so
for those who miss the show please go to
lordsgaming.net
please vote the engagement really helps
us plus supports the tremendous riders
that we got yeah we got something it's
like i said
keep in mind if you guys want to have
your own little pole man yeah
we we we do have uh tears for that right
so we got to so basically trying to do a
little bit like
attic was saying a little bit more fan
engagement we're noticing in the patreon
tiers you know people are
coming up with polls they want to do
that so yeah that's what we got
anyway let's get our outros going i
think oh look at
that she left her luca gave her outro so
salute to her but
um still here to kick you i was like
okay
bro no doubt no doubt you already know
she wants to talk that nonsense yeah
we're going to talk about talking
about the attack for the moment so we're
going to talk about that we're going to
turn that away
with the bikes without having them so
let's get
mommy lord addict where can i find
people find you what you got going on
sir
you can find me on twitter at lord
addicts ilp you can find me on youtube
gaming addict yes i will be resuming uh
content tomorrow um
i had a lot of i needed i needed a
mental breakdown i feel like bro i feel
like it was it was just doing too much
yeah
right my destiny clan attacked me though
but same for me
the destiny clan so what you do four
shows listen in action
that's your business the the destiny
yeah that's it the destiny clan know
better to be expecting me to be there
every time
so uh definitely well first off i want
to you know thank lord dan for coming on
i want to thank luca for coming on even
though she slanders me
but you know i definitely appreciate it
it's like i said you know luca luca has
a very uh
very entertaining show yes it definitely
goes on the cast
we put that in the comments section if
you're still in there hustle
drop that in the comment section for out
here helping us get us down
i i i want to appreciate everyone for
coming through like i said
we'll be doing a little bit more uh
interaction when it comes to stuff
i'm going to talk to the lords after
this i try to give you guys a little bit
more content that's not necessarily
uh what we normally do we'll see exactly
what we can do
on it obviously a lot of this you know
what we already do
a lot from our day-to-day for iop uh
and you know thanks to and it's all for
you guys you know we
we we really put a lot of work to make
sure we give you guys the best show we
possibly can every week
and we're just gonna try to expand that
and you know do a little bit more
content that you guys might not
necessarily get from the podcast that
you might be able to get outside the
podcast and i definitely appreciate
everyone for coming through
uh we we had a lot of people in here
yeah you guys are always supportive
every week man and
it looks like a's winning uh the the po
oh okay he's working okay i just want to
make sure
i like they put that pole in there man i
like that but we also
again because we need some engagement
you know we got riders on
on launch gaming now i'm also going to
put the poll on lawyergaming.net so
please if you can if you're here
it really helps the engagement for us an
algorithm seo
when you guys click the link and
actually vote on the site
it really helps us and keep in mind
that poll that's in there is just for
you guys to vote live
next week when we do that thing that's
not going to be in the stats for
the actual podcast like if you want to
be part of the people
stating your opinion next week you got
to do it on the website because that's
the only one that's getting read next
week
yeah thank you man i really really
appreciate it like i said please support
lordsagegaming.net
those are our brothers and sisters
phenomenal writers like they they are
killing in the lord's minute
that the lords are doing it's fine yeah
yeah no doubt no doubt so let's get lord
solved where can the five people find
what you got going on sir
i got nothing going on i'm going back to
my regular schedule so i'm done for oh
no
no more no more parents no no no no no
shout out today for coming through shout
out to luca for coming through a bit of
a minute
um yeah so we'll see we might have some
gaming that
going on next week baby lord king
bringing the smoke winning all the polls
except skyward sword
where could the fight be proper we're
getting to five people find you what you
got going on sir
first i want to give a shout out to uh
lord damn
um the only person that can get me to
bend a knee to get chipped
out there was no way around it uh now i
always know where king is oh yeah
everybody pull up the androids and
you'll see me just walking around and
you have
i'm done i'm gonna be like my phone
gonna beep off because i have a diameter
it's like if king gets a certain close
to my house
why is he here i have to kick the king
pull up at a proximity
he said 343 watching only 79 volts yeah
hit that like button y'all come back
i really ask
shout out to luca yo it's she different
when she played online
so i i thought let me let me explain
your please yeah
she come with all the smoke yeah not
online like when we play it
no no no no this is totally different
look and then she saw a different king
so i don't know maybe she was in shock
like okay i got you i got it
no no no usually when i'm okay so when i
play rage i'm focused on getting the
rage
so like that's like my primary focus
there and i i don't want to be a
detriment to the team so i typically
keep my mouth shut especially if it's
still like new for me
yeah yeah but it was it was a great
experience and even then on
when we was playing it i was like oh man
you need to come on the show we need to
get you on the show
when you pop that i was like
[Music]
so you know i need to get myself on
scumcast yes you're welcome anytime any
of you are welcome anytime
you know what to do just hit me up and
i'll definitely be there um
yo it's great show today i i i love you
guys as y'all can see
who's spinning into the background i had
a lot of questions about electro and the
reason why i didn't do electro on kos
was i didn't have a story phone
oh okay okay and i i went back i got all
my books all my spider-man books and i
was going through it and i was going
through it
and and then this is classic electro
brought to you by
um uh sram one
no no this is xml ogre yeah uh the great
daniel bell sculpted that
so daniel bell is the same person that
scored the silver surfer
and did iron fists and a couple of other
uh great stuff we got to talk about you
still got that got you man
oh yeah you want to have a conversation
with a conversation
okay oh no no i just thought about i've
been in this got your man back
i kind of yeah it's for sale all right
the thing the thing is i have to get a
craft the story and i found the perfect
story
uh electro only has one really
meaningful story and
and i try to give you a background
history on stuff for kos so if you see
kos pop
up you know um i'm not going there
trying to be the best
uh statue guy on youtube i'm not trying
to be
even though it locate you all over
what i'm trying to do is just give you a
glimpse into why i got something
100 better than all these dudes that
don't give you no back stories or show
us at you continue
yeah and then and they they they go to
wikipedia yeah type
in
that's going to go up this week um shout
out to laura cognito and
lord attic for helping me in the
background for when that stuff goes up
that is a group effort
yo um yeah i'm doing the edits yeah i'm
doing the whatever stuff but there's a
lot of stuff
when you go to the website when you go
to logicgaming.net
uh there's a whole synopsis if you want
to know the weight of the status
and you want to know uh who's the
manufacturer and how you can order and
what's going on and all this other stuff
there is a whole thing that's put up
there and that stuff is put up there
through hard work at the website shout
out on the youtube
as well with some thumbnails from
addicts yeah stuff like that
group effort group effort king kills it
with the the commentary the
the backstory just not just showing you
a statue and then running away
because he got a hot statue he's giving
you real synapses you know i'm saying
that's one
addict is killing it on the youtube side
getting the production value up doing
what we got to do to make that thing
shine
and i want to shout out our
editor-in-chief josh redding
who definitely puts the shine on the
king article you know what i'm saying to
get you those dimensions to get you the
extra stats and all that other stuff
and then king puts it out so yeah salute
to the whole team effort
kos very proud of that and yo support my
brother like he's killing it man like
any time he puts it out
it is fire you know what i mean i'm just
going to talk about it's better
uh we're getting back to some normalcy
we had some big fights so
i i'm my my juices is paul's definitely
flowing now
so i'm back into the situation it's kind
of dull
when you don't have an arena with people
yeah there to do stuff so no doubt and
that's it you already know me lord
cognition look again salute lord dan
paul
do cognito you know what i said well
it sounds like a b-rated marvel here
duke meadows
it makes me think of uh boss from dark
souls one dark soul
i want to say something before you go
out before you close like right at the
very end oh no no doubt but yes look to
the homie uh maddie plays
again i want to thank the community
y'all showing me so much love y'all
making me feel
home you know welcome and everybody you
know what i'm saying the whole team
it's been really fun to do and like i
said i'll be back on last word don't
think i got hollywood on last word your
boy had the ear fish i can't show you
here look crazy
but um yo i'll be back on that and uh
yeah we got mad fun things playing crazy
good guess
a lot of stuff cooking please keep the
support the likes up loads of gaming
down there all that good stuff
and attic i'm gonna let you close what
you got before we get out of here yeah
so i will be returning
to the attic show this tuesday but uh so
definitely turn into that
but for today go over there and show it
show following some love
yes go over there tell them the iop sent
you tell them the lord sent you man uh
yo it's a great show he's got neo spark
on walker
youtube channel support you already know
we see y'all next week
bye
[Music]
and now we out for real
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]